foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pop out what's going on black conflict X
you already know what it is akw it's the
ordinary David hot right super excited I
got ready for this one this one seems
special
what's going on guys
[Music]
sold God soul is in here
[Music]
oh no it's Alex trying to find Kate
trying to find us off
thank you brother
wow that's good that's crazy akw that's
hilarious where's the host of the
podcast
don't do that see he's doing too much of
it
anyway about to go get directions
fun topics for the show
start getting people late
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social but
I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal I
got you that's
[Music]
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when he was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
titty but I'm still by Coastal I got you
man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social but
I'm still by Coastal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn
look You Oughta messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
they real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still
bicosal I got
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all to Dramatical I know it's
random but I'm addicted to flipping and
Sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless and people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down
look You Oughta messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
ain't real but come to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
using these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless messaging people
don't aim check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm anti-social or my city but I'm
still by Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
whoo
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless messaging people on AIM check
my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social but I'm still by Coastal I
got you
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot to get
comfortable grab a snack do all the good
stuff that we need to do in um you know
we're about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headless be swearing
they real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start it regardless
and people don't aim check my vocals all
on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
cool
there you go everybody up here they
would go to school
over here it's real though still
I feel like we're making a mistake I
don't know why but I feel like
we're about to come across like a giant
spider or something
a hold on you go without the light man
thank you
what's up here what's up here oh we made
it to the other side
[Music]
where's Costco
all right let's let's get our bearings
in here
I'm going out the other way
you didn't come with us
wait I saw that spider I'm going out the
other way
s
[Music]
I'ma just chill and watch them when he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they will mistake me for addict
if I can imagine it's cool to get you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't get with
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get sauce
in the bushes by King David royalty and
not a pretender detrimental to an
elemental was an avatar to a knee Bender
I gotta be me though I know it's my
destiny Works who cares if he flies you
stealing mosquito you swear you ain't
nothing but really be Stevo you like to
collect stuff
[Music]
[Music]
if you got work on a Sunday You're
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
good
evening
I'm hot we're going hot we just check
the levels right quick say something
real quick addict let's make sure levels
you got crispy I see that crispy that's
just that right quick is that is that
better on this side because I know I'm
the one having the issues today hold on
you clear you clear and the mic here you
hear ye and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast LLC and also live on
Lords of gaming.net someone in any
cheering the chat Alex yes
[Laughter]
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's day I'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got Brazil approving the Xbox
Activision deal
fix your face PlayStation live service
games day and date to PC and OverWatch
2's launch to discuss so we could get
right into it yo the chat is already
putting pepperoni
pepperoni means oh yeah I have no idea
so if anybody donates like a 50 on my
screen I take off my shirt night dance
oh they want the show all right so we go
you might have one of my pepperoni
nipples wow okay he will not be doing
any pepperoni today
pepperoni will not be happening
please
oh my God
the pepperonios
look I'm you're gonna lose all your
sponsors today
this is great Lord I want to introduce
the Lord whose Ascension as an
Entertainer yet informative content
trainer has truly been a sight to behold
not only does this Lord exude a true
passion for gaming in its live streams
and PC Port analysis but always finds a
way to weaponize the emotionality of
extreme fanboys
introducing the created host of the oh
no it's Alex YouTube channel
the Lord of Fanboy salt accumulation
lady Erica's side gaming husband with
the most
electrifying thigh slap in the game
live from Florida and finally making his
debut into the realm of the Lord my man
Lord oh no it's Alex how we doing sir
what's up y'all it's me it's your boy
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's here he's here
it's done what's going on
good man good I'm happy to be here I
know it's been a minute um addict has
been trying to get me on for a while
um but I basically remodel my house on
my own okay and make content at the same
time and I sell feet picks on only
friends so you know I'm a busy guy he
was out here hustling baby he's out here
do what it do you know you want some
size 13s in your inbox
you ready to go ready to go
you didn't say I couldn't be
assassinated
I think I think attic joined my stream
last night to see what it would be like
today and he was like oh
automatically regret it please yeah no
what you've been playing so what games
have been going on with you
um so I just finished the outer worlds
which is really good
and I am addicted to
um a game called Path of Exile have you
guys played that you guys the sermon
okay let's go let's go okay so Path of
Exile is a Diablo like RPG what they
basically did was uh they took Diablo 2
and they injected it with dynabol and as
much steroid as possible there are three
skill trees the best way I can describe
it is each skill tree is like if you
take every single Final Fantasy 10 skill
tree you slam it into one and that's
your one skill tree okay
so you just it's like you can do
anything you want with any character
okay and so they do Leagues so every
three months they introduce a new
mechanic into the game and then you you
basically start from zero all over again
but the thing is it's incredibly
difficult and you basically need like a
lot of time patience and understanding
of like math it's all like percentage
based gotcha so it's like oh this one
skill gem will give you 20 uplift on
your attack speed and you're like oh
that's like two that's like two points
it's not like you gotta like figure [ __ ]
out you gotta figure it out it'll sound
good and then you're like oh no but then
when you start like figuring stuff out
it starts rolling all the mechanics
through it's it's [ __ ] oh sorry it's
really nuts
I appreciate you brother I appreciate
you yeah
Exile you're good
um the outer worlds and now I'm playing
uh so what I do is I'm really weird I
install a game out of the letter of the
alphabet
for every letter and those are the 26
games I play that year okay okay you got
the alphabetical Association let me ask
you real quick what um Auto worlds did
you do the uh the murderer on aradano's
DLC did the whole thing apparel goggles
I just did the main stuff got you I wish
it was good yeah they're coming out I
think they're about to release it
re-release it and call like a spacious
Choice Edition where they'll have all of
it combined but um yeah man Murad or
Domino's is that's probably the best
content we got obsidian on it's
hilarious the writing is really good but
that amazing the writing is really good
yeah yeah I made my character like
um
you guys ever watch Firefly I have done
a little bit a little bit back in the
day yeah so Firefly the main character
of firefly is who I made my character
like so he was a smooth talker and he
always used a pistol
so that's how I did it and I was like a
smart question for you right let's say
you picked your 26 games for the year
you went down the list
and the game drops
if you really like it
and something is occupying that letter
yeah do you go back and revisit the list
or is it a hard list and to see you next
year I don't care what you did I don't
care if you came out at all
uh so a lot of games that are coming out
are bad
so it really doesn't matter both
bad broken or both yeah like uh the new
Arkham game oh it doesn't look good
it doesn't look good I don't want to
hear lizard
you ain't about that what what an insult
to to one of the greatest female
characters of all time in comics yeah I
think I didn't when I saw that what the
hell are they doing and it was supposed
to be this empowering moment I was like
no they got it wrong
they got that complete let's let me give
you one of the most you know
quintessential characters in the Batman
lore have her go through one of the most
traumatic experiences any person can go
through a matter of what men or woman uh
have her overcome that overcome
literally being paralyzed from the waist
down and then as she becomes one of the
best fighters of all time and detectives
play Livin la Vida
that's a smart man
nobody read a comic that's hilarious Yo
shout out to the audio file they say it
Alex's audio is popping slowly yeah you
are popping a little slightly so I know
baby it's about fault for having him is
that better all right let's see the a
sound real smooth average less though I
see hustle in there thank you no no we
ain't gonna ask him to leave just let us
know now awesome
to leave and come back
popping popping is probably just like
I'm too loud yeah it could be yeah
you're still popping a little I'll come
back I'll even come back all right no
doubt why are we doing that while Alex
is getting it together you know we still
got the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords of the round at the round
table my co-host with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord attic of the attic show how we
doing sir
doing pretty good you guys can thank uh
Forte for how my camera looks right now
yeah we we spent like two hours on it
man it was building a lot now whatever
you learned
how you doing
to be honest with you there was so much
stuff I don't even know what I learned
oh man
yeah that's when somebody don't want to
help you with me like it was a lot of
work bro
it can't be repeated it can't happen
you know I'm a little annoyed with with
Sony and these manufacturers that make
these cameras like I get it you know
these are designed for what we do them
for like we use you know third-party
attachments to trick the PC into
thinking it's a webcam pretty
essentially but it's just like
Sony you know people do this so why why
can't I adjust settings on my PC with an
app then I happen to take off my pc okay
so how's that look for today okay good
Saturn for now that's not it
it's just like look man like you know
people use these cameras for this this
isn't just something we do everyone does
this make an app like like
let me and even if you can't do it with
these models because it's like software
limitations next ones make it to where
you can adjust the settings on your
actual PC like before you asking that to
do that everyone is one person
specifically that you just you just said
one person
you know well it's I'm gonna say one
dude
who's your camera by Sir
we talked about that last uh last week
but besides that we uh you know for
those of you that saw we we showed a
little bit of you know a little snippet
of the uh grounded one grounded gameplay
we did yesterday now I'm fun what's
funny is there's more to that part than
there is there but I couldn't I couldn't
look it was like four minutes long
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to cut
it back because after that we we didn't
know this but there the exit leaving
that cave you can't get to so we had to
go through the spiders
the moment you dropped down to kill
those ants Cog literally took us into a
kill box that there was no return from
under armored I at that fault was
terrorizing with them two little soldier
eggs and I needed to have my goals and
you exchanged some Soldier ads for
ads for a wolf spider look I can't show
the randomness yeah
I was like looking up like you know like
tips and stuff about grounded that game
is huge yeah like they I have to like
I still would prefer an RPG from from
obsidian but man I have to say like they
they're a very talented students isn't
it like an RPG survival you get what I'm
saying though like like an outer worlds
type of RPG but I I have to say that
grind is a good game man I I was wrong
about that game
it's fun it's fun I I think it is one of
those games that it benefits greatly off
who you play with but I was really
enjoying that game when I had a good
time yesterday three hours went by like
nothing realized it yeah yeah and when I
looked up after I got a text from my
wife
and she said you said you was only going
to be on for an hour
did time fly I wanted I wanted to put
the one part King got killed like three
times by a spider okay that's it where
are the guns
there's no guns in here did we get the
craft guns because I gotta shoot a
spider anyway that's better addict isn't
it
yeah playing a lot of grounded not
allowed to talk about another game I'm
playing about but uh actually after the
podcast Alex uh we need to talk I I
might I might have an extra code for
this game for you oh okay well
um if you like grounded may I suggest
rust
yeah okay that game intimidates me
[Music]
how is the hand holding though like I
need to be my hand here is one of those
what hand holder yeah exactly exactly
that's why grout is for me I need the
basic survival do this because I have no
objective I do nothing
I gotta rely on Excellence like y'all I
mean if you want guns just play Escape
from tarkov yeah that's fine what you
call Sim plays that a lot no see but the
but those spiders that terrorizing us
they're not almost okay
you know the whole point of quinoa want
a gun is he wanted he wanted Revenge
Alex do you understand how rough it is
when uh you go into a world that you
have no idea what's going on but then
you see this Hawking monster right and
you say all right fine like in all games
I'm just gonna run and I'm gonna hide
behind something and the AI is so stupid
he's not gonna find me
another one I was I was making it like I
grabbed my book bag and I'll make it
over and it killed me and I come back
grab my bookbag make it over he'll kill
me
I can't confirm or deny this but Alex
like one of the one of the spiders got
stuck in a cave like a little tunnel and
they sent another spider to back him up
he's stuck he's stuck okay we're gonna
send this other spider to kill these
people okay it was wow it was wild I
would love them to use that AI style
when they make a vowed
hopefully talk to me that'd be cool like
if what if what if grounded is like a
just like a test bed for like AI
um
I think so they would just do that and
of course we got to get into it we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer lives for the single player self
experience and also disastradamus the
Lord of clarity and Lord patreon of the
iron bank my man Lord sovereign
apologies for yesterday I could not make
it I was at work and today I also have
work and I actually have to leave a
little bit early take care of something
um so apologies in advance for that um
so this week what did I do
um so the only thing I really got to
play a little bit of was uh Moon scars
the game that uh that Kings talk about
last week right yes yes so I got it on
the steam deck that game is wow
you got game pass on Steam deck don't
you no I don't sir
[Laughter]
[Applause]
local play you you I'm not supporting
anything not about local nothing I'm not
I'm not surprised
there you go Alex thank you
see I'm on TV
not for supporting something that you
can get for free uh-huh you just
flagrantly just going out there buying
stuff
I had to pay for my game pass I don't
know about you yeah
mine is not that's right
bill for that game pass yeah Game Pass
is not free why don't you come up with
this man all right
um
he was right man yo when it comes to
like just the action the variety of
moves that you can unlock the animation
no it is crazy and it's a difficult game
and it has my my favorite you know
Harry's you give me a Parry I mean I'm
happy I'm happy you always like gays
with them you love Paris with Perry's
like I think the most satisfying Perry
was in like Sakura when you when you did
the one we're here
I don't know why every time I did that I
was like let's go
you know I would never know that because
I went out like a fool and brought that
game because it was like the Game of the
Year Edition or whatever the hell it was
and then he was like it was dope yeah
the two dudes in the front in the front
yeah because everybody was like tattoo
attention didn't you and it's like not
really yeah you know what's funny when
when smooth stream that game and he got
suplex like 80 times by that first yeah
they said it's the um yeah
yeah so that um my only grandmother's
team deck is that those pixels are small
so that game is super small on the steam
deck okay good for you
sir
listen I'm not I'm just saying so fine
what is the steam deck hate in this
podcast
two individuals two individuals Alex
it's not hate it's just you have to
listen to the high jealousy wow
they walk across the room this guy that
is sitting above you I guess over to the
left maybe so extra with the man I feel
like they they put a little bit yeah
whenever they talk about it but this guy
walked directly past Game Pass
and threw his money over the gate and
they hand him a back a a bad pixel what
you say was wrong with you getting your
pixels
the pixels are small because the screen
is smaller you know when you go to your
Xbox the pixels is fine anyway
can I go to your house and play on your
TV while you go to work for me
so here's my question here's my name
already invested inside of steam with PC
gaming oh yeah so then why would he buy
another device where he has to buy the
game again if you can just buy a
portable device to play all his entire
library for that he's already paid for
yeah
you know what and then and then choices
and play it at a higher and better
Fidelity and and resolution when I do
decide to play on my TV
back to you Jim anyway
so that and oh and so Friday I went to
New York Comic-Con yeah I forgot about
that yeah
for some other stuff yeah so I went with
a lord marlonia shut up he was there he
was there for business reasons but then
we also decided to sort of walk around
and see what was because I've never been
a comic con
um
Comic-Con is yeah first of all like it's
the amount of people people are excited
to be back going to these conventions
that it was uh there were a lot of
people there A lot of Cosplay everybody
having fun it was despite the amount of
people at you know no issues everybody
was you know super polite I mean I think
we've experienced that at like packs and
stuff like that yeah never really any
issues but there were a lot of people at
the Javits Center yeah that's what I
always try to tell people when people
was like oh this person's read that
person's route as I look like they
there's some bad seats but when you go
to these events and you're on like
thousands and thousands of people you
realize the majority of people are chill
it's just very chill
and everybody's really yeah nobody's
really looking to oh you bumped into me
nothing like that like it was just
something it was really something to
Behold a lot of amazing costumes to see
um yeah the cosplay was crazy
I took some no no not a lot because I'm
one of those weirdos bro oh yeah I don't
stop
I watched a documentary on how people
get ready for these shows and they hand
craft this stuff they don't yeah it's
ridiculous things and they look
phenomenal yeah well I just you know hey
man can I take a picture if it's okay
and they they want that too like I know
a bunch of cosplayers like they feel
offended if they spent 20 hours making
the helmet of their cosplay and no one
asked them to take it I mean they have I
don't know if you guys have seen this at
other uh Comic Cons they had a station
where you can pay to have them spray
paint an entire costume onto you there
was yeah they had a station you should
be naked
had a girl who paid she was in you know
because like bikinis and then they spray
painted and then uh
you didn't call me
I could have literally went there okay
naked and had stopped snitching on
myself
the king remind me of that moment too
fast too
fake call Brian I'll be there in five
minutes
it was it was very cool but when I
realized it it isn't super for me
anymore like I I'm not into the comics
as much anymore right so a lot of people
just you know kind of selling their
Wares and stuff that that main floor
that's what it is yeah and then the
lower floor had like tabletop gaming and
then all the stuff like it's different
than pastors packs everything that's on
the show floor is games and it's the
devs talking to you about the games
which is really what you know what we're
there for this is different this is just
people kind of selling their Wares you
know stuff like that um you do have
booze I was looking for ever born I
guess everyone wasn't there this year
um but um you know you have creators and
stuff in the uh comic creators that are
there signing and stuff they had the
creator of He-Man I believe that was
there signing stuff and like a lot of
Hanna-Barbera stuff so that was cool
um yeah but then when you look at like
all the panels and stuff that they talk
about the new announcements those are
all pan animals that happen in separate
rooms upstairs in like and like on the
main stage so the lines for that stuff
is great Bonkers like none of that stuff
is out so that was a little
disappointing when you look at packs and
the amount of access you have this is
very sort of cordoned off right so that
was disappointing in another episode we
went upstairs for you didn't it feel
like E3 when they let the people in yeah
it kind of did it does when they let the
people in and they was trying to sell
you everything yeah you know that's
that's what I didn't like it was all
about the free stuff when that was took
away he was he was done that's the thing
like when there's the people in the swag
goes out the window everything is for
sale yeah you know what I mean I didn't
like Comic Con for that no doubt yeah
but it was it was a nice experience but
uh not really for me anymore I feel good
for you and of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the excess
gamer the prophet of Xbox Swami King of
the statues who demands nothing less
than that premium experience it is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
I'm doing fantastic plastic today
um got a chance to chill this weekend is
a long weekend we had a full moon on
Friday so you know all the crazies was
out
I had a great time looking at all the
crazies downtown
um I got a chance to play uh wind bound
okay and it's uh it's on Game Pass
surprise surprise
[Laughter]
excuse me excuse me I partake at the
buffet oh okay okay
just the guy that brings in his own
french fries when he goes to McDonald's
[Laughter]
get to you anyway so
it's we was playing grounded yesterday
yes sir and early in the week I was
playing uh wind bound
and it's a survival crafting game and it
reminds me of one week a little bit
because you have to you know make a raft
and you you it's about to see and it's a
exploration
really cool game really
nice art direction oh music is very
subtle
um and it holds your hand a little bit
and then it leads you off to Greater
passages and you do great things but I
just want to clarify just real quick you
know you don't make a raft in Wind Waker
continue oh my God I'm moving them
that was that was super messy continue
the game is really good I suggest you if
you're looking for anything new to try
and check out just gonna go try and
check it out if you have Game Pass if I
don't know if it's on PlayStation Plus
but if it is try it out over there if
you get a chance it's probably on Steam
I'll try that out
I didn't like that I didn't like what
you try to do continue
I'll be sure to check it out thank you
okay I'll be sure to check it out and
Steve deck thanks
no other than I was playing fortnite I
finally got that uh character that I
wanted out uh the teddy bear with the
other teddy bear in the middle my
stomach just so he's a giant gummy and
he's a he's a suit yeah
[Laughter]
and he's playing the giant teddy bear on
outside it's it's ridiculous it's funny
you're playing with fortnite yes sir
yeah he played with it
Alex I I agree I didn't like fortnite
when they didn't do it when they do the
build the Eiffel Tower stuff but ever
since they you know gave you a mode
where you don't have to uh worry about
people building the Empire State
Building when you fight them uh I I have
actually really enjoyed my time with
fortnite
and we get shamed Alex
what's the point of building forts you
go in night night
all right so
on to you Alex so
um I have uh children that don't live in
my household and for me to connect and
bond with my son he plays fortnite
that's what you do let's go do it I
don't have kids and I still play
fortnite and you have no excuse Alex
a week later after I joined because I
was so sick and tired of building stuff
and I was just dying all the time it had
no build mode yeah I heard that's what
it is and I really got hooked to the
game after that so really as soon as he
gets out of school I'm like texting him
yo
get on
because yeah
oh he's 11. he's 11. okay perfect let's
introduce him to a beautiful game called
Counter-Strike
here we go
baby
that's the best age yeah
that's how you get them tough early
and I can't wait to get back on doing it
no doubt and of course you have to give
me ninja himself the Shinobi long
cognito's friend ever listen to the
rubbing IOP not telling what you want to
hear what you need to hear should I do
shout out to Mr Maddie plays had a good
defiant Duke talk about what's going on
with the Activision Blizzard stuff all
that good stuff also um talk about the
positional remakes I know that's a hot
one we'll probably touch a little bit
shout out to finally do ultimate did the
spoiler cast about the edge Runners The
cyberpunk Edge Runners Journey so we had
that shout out to Chris Ray Gun who
pulled up pretty fun and then last word
I like Chris yeah Chris was doing his
thing man he's easy Beast shout out to
the last word he boss is on vacation
little crew tools but um yeah we had a
little kind of getting to know you
episode where we kind of asked each
other at least like personal questions
non-destly related which is hilarious we
did that and then well as far as me
obviously did the ground extreme with
y'all you know I'm saying Still rocking
that was my first time doing a co-op
situation and then it was um it was
really good I've been a master of the
OverWatch server page it was waiting I
was a master that I went from 300 in the
queue to 40 000 in the queue you know
what I'm saying put up big numbers on
launch date it goes backwards
like what's funny is I try to play that
with my girl for like three days and
she's just like babe I don't want to
play this anymore
you would like this intro husband is
here
you got to go back yeah if you was in
the beginning you're gonna like the
issue I cooked up for so you got that
going on but um yeah it's been that and
then um yeah I think that's pretty much
yeah how much is your weekend did you
spend praying for the Mets
like they not only did they like about
the point so I'm not gonna allow them to
down my spirit with they foolishness so
when they blew the division I was like
oh man I'm not even to you Jimmy anyway
and then now with this but I was here
last night I was praying everything I
was like please please and then they did
a shout out to Edwin Diaz shout out the
Lord sucre doing this thing shout out to
the squirrel McNeil when I was doing
that but anyway enough sports for
addicts so he don't go crazy let's get
into the test and then we got to get
into the Alex situation
[Laughter]
every time you have to click on another
link to see a tweet on Twitter that's
where I draw the line I'm not going to
the Twitter let's get these super chats
off oh no I didn't take my time
man five dollar Super Chat all hail the
mighty king and the Lord I'm starting a
GoFundMe for Chris Hart he deserves to
have premium customer service as well
it's not right wow
hilarious now we got the wandering Dutch
member for 15 months
Sunday Alex and King will be bringing
the spicy takes today salute the IOP
Brothers no doubts you already know
we got chaos Santi five dollars
happy Sunday all can't catch it live
today hanging with the fan but looking
forward to catching up later salute to
the ilpu as well enjoy time with the
fans great show yesterday yes
then we got Kuno mats two dollar Super
Chat everybody knows everybody knows
frit is the king of salt oh no
we'll see about that we got Alex in the
building
we have a heartbeat she need remember
for one year five dollars a chat so look
to the Lord's cognite pushing powder at
the beginning what's going on
shout out to get that Focus up you know
saying get that energy line you know I'm
thinking on that sour right now you know
I'm just saying
there we have oh no it's Alex or is it
Ben Affleck in the house
do you get that off
that is good absolutely so true yeah let
me explain to you guys what what my
viewers do to me because this is like I
don't understand if you guys like the
kind of culture I've created in my in my
channel uh uh my viewers love to insult
me so uh right now apparently I am bald
oh damn
uh I have Tourette's and
um I uh I have very small muscles and I
have pepperoni nipples so now like in my
chat all you see is ball ball but it's
just they just Spam it yeah
so now they're here now they're here
doing it I love it
I was looking at the chat and I was just
like okay I love it somebody said oh no
it's Ben Affleck yo they stupid
so what I do is instead of like getting
mad about it I just lean into it yeah
where I just had like would you do you
just have to right so now it's not like
what I do is I make fake keeps
commercials
[Laughter]
that keeps losing you turn
you disarm trolls and made them fans
[ __ ] listen yeah that's that's really
that's really funny because like I am
I'm only blocked by like two people on
Twitter
and then everybody else is like and they
follow me it's well it's because like
the way I can block you make a three
yeah I do it and then what I do is I I
have a thing right I don't like to go to
like a personal insult but I mean that's
why I respect you
so I mean the worst I'll do is call you
the r word yeah and then or like I'll
say like go stack boxes yes that's about
it but what I do is like I'll just I'll
just like break down your entire
argument and then I'll make you look
like an idiot and you're like oh let go
hold that door we go we're gonna touch
that we're going to touch that we almost
did get this that's why I don't get
blocked I respect it big time
they're gonna be showing no legs for
Alex calm down
you guys want some ties
that's when he slapped the left eye and
the right
No Doubt
is it Chanel or the channel was he
trying to say I don't know
yep it says Chanel so I say yup yup
because we got Dragonheart yo beat
member for one year finalized hashtag
peace love life you as well my brother
thank you so sit down those legs are
awesome
continue and we have let me play with
your children
two dollar Super Chat can we get solved
to slap his thighs too
bro we should put up a patreon Tim bro
you gotta get offense what they want
after this
swipe his size on streams
pepperoni Sundays yes for me to stop my
thighs on streamo would have to actually
put pants on thank you
we need some big donuts for sovereign
[Laughter]
again remember for 16 months keep up the
great work Lords I've been doing my
homework watching the old uh shows from
the beginning King David was a monster
back then haters don't want that guy
back don't [ __ ] up
on me
remember for 17 months you guys should
cut up the gameplay and send out the
highlights of funny moments of the
stream in a 10 to 15 minute video
you told me not to what I thought you
said you're gonna break him up and put
them on the um the Tic Tacs and all that
no they they want it on a YouTube video
they want the greatest highlights on a
YouTuber
he said what did you go slice that up
and put that on them
screw it over there
on the tick tock and Alex I thought I
was the oldest person
almost 40.
oh let's go oh we're in the same pocket
good morning to the IOP Alex Alex Alex
Xbox has started a slow burn to the
number one market position and
Playstation as we know it is doomed just
had to get this out of the way ABK
approvals rolling in like B2B day one
PlayStation games that PC did he what
did I hear that right yes day one there
will be day one games on PC yeah
don't get spicy because I'll just turn
right around and do Xbox fan boys
don't get too comfortable exactly you're
getting too comfy I'm not your boy
what's your Twitter handle let's get
this video
wow the dragon are you remember when he
had 20 last Super Chat if the Lord's
ever at a convention then let me play
with your joystick is there don't be
surprised if SOB goes missing for 30
minutes
getting his shirt ripped up look at this
oriented got kidnapped security we gotta
protect all of it yeah man listen man I
walk around I walk around with me
I said I'm the greatest fan
hey guys hey guys
but I need to bring up a real issue free
R Kelly is on 23 hour lockdown and he
shouldn't have to decide between
commissary and paying for a fee to start
his place
he on the yard continue
then we have Nova 30 M3 member for nine
months thank you so much love the
grounded stream fantastic game Xbox the
home of four player co-op grounded sea
of Thieves in State of Decay amazing
multiplayer experiences
we got free R Kelly oh here you go five
dollars of a check nobody cares about
Brazil God gonna be on Sony for seven
more years Microsoft's just leasing God
okay okay responds
tails you was worried about Brazil and
you said that wasn't going to be a
problem
and then I happened
only stop switching movie we back on
that lights out carols
we've told you multiple times man spend
spend that money on some ramen noodles I
know it's hungry
gaming the Lord's welcome to salute the
fathers
go play your bunk
like that
can't say but can't wait to listen to
tomorrow have a great day
salute hey look at look listen if you
plug one I gotta look a boat for you
no no you didn't know I didn't know yeah
all right okay let's see what we doing I
see with the bottle is w-a-t-a don't
play with me
let's get it let's get it
let's buy it that's fine I had no idea
that's what's up you learned something
this is yeah Cedric as out I'll tell you
so remember for 28 months thank you so
much then we have Donut Taco remember
for one year two dollars to the chat
where's the Super Mario movie topic you
cowards look at that dollar tacos
we can briefly talk about that because a
lot of people are talking about it ain't
nothing wrong with it
they didn't see an issue with it yeah
I actually don't think he did a bad job
in the little that we did we didn't even
hear a lot like you know what it was bad
they're comparing it it's funny it's
funny because they have uh they were
comparing it to the uh French voice
acting
yeah the French voice acting sounds like
Mario but yeah obviously he's talking
more and it sounded like one would
expect Mario to sound I don't I need to
hear more of Chris Pratt what I heard I
wasn't impressed with but again I'm not
offended by it I thought it sounded fine
I didn't have an issue because this was
that he sounded like this Pratt as
opposed to Prairie that's what I heard
like Chris Pat just trying to do like a
New York accents I'm like it was not
yeah yeah so you guys maybe it's because
I'm not like really uh like emotionally
invested in the Mario character so it
doesn't really bother me yeah no I
looked at it I said it looks dope it
looks good yeah it looks good all right
so uh Pratt he's in it okay so what I
can't have everything I rather that be
the problem than it look horrible oh
yeah like remember when we first saw
Sonic yeah yeah yeah okay no doubt no
doubt remember we got BK born gaming ten
dollars what's goody hope everyone is
having a good weekend shout out to the
homie Alex
so then we got Hollywood rules remember
for six months five dollar Super Chat
watching ball just wanted to wish my
video game cousins a great show best
video game podcast on YouTube Hey Cog
let's go Mets quick show guys yeah let's
get it
all right then we had hold on a couple
of them won't come in face 23 BK and why
oh no Super Chat Xbox fans got their
groove back like Stella for how long we
shall see oh he's being respectful today
yeah I thought he's gonna get some nice
Xbox land thanks Xbox
okay salute being cool I respected
he's looking for allies when the war
really breaks out
when it goes when it goes south he's
lost I was real respectful you know
then we got Tom from Toonami two dollar
Super Chat R.I.P Blue Jays yeah I
thought I thought this was your house
Vlad this is your house
continue yeah we got top of two numbers
again let's put the crest in the chat
for Tom from Toonami welcome to the Lord
then we got GSD AKA getting stuff done
five dollar Super Chat the Lords and
pepperoni Lex definitely crossed the
streams
I just caught that I didn't cross any
streams
yeah
straight My Stream
take it as a Ghostbusters reference you
have to go there
look it's really simple right you've
never had the black and white cookies
from Seinfeld oh
we doing what was that other cookie
oh all fillings see I already know Alex
all right nobody do it move it off then
we have played five dollars how many
buckaroos I heard that the first 10 IOP
episodes are being remastered to be sold
for 70 bucks a piece and he chewed to
this half a great show
there's a an inside joke to that Alex
when we we had like it was probably like
more like 10 to 11 I think it was 10.
but when we got King and solved when we
won away from the destiny only podcast I
just deleted them
technically they deserve a remaster
because you're right I just deleted them
we took the first tip because
technically we're 10 we're 10 podcasts
ahead ahead of you yeah we acted like
that that's very nice salute then we
have cool beanie gaming five dollars
Alex we played a switch emulator split
screen on our PC 60 FPS two games two
Xbox controllers PC Master race do we
agree Alexis exactly what you got to do
is I mean the PC can be anything you
want it doesn't have to be all Graphics
emulate everything is really nice okay
that's the absolute masturbation ability
to continue
good morning Lord It's good to see Alex
on today no doubt no doubt Lord
then we have Texas five dollars we chat
it's the Lord's Day IOP salute Alex your
shoulders
your shoulders a lot of inside jokes
okay a lot of inside jokes
that we have let me see we got it jump
we got Corey Hale 20 Super Chat have a
great show fellas bang bang nine again
yeah let's go Jimmy G let's go see me I
said I prologue
the greatest model on the team I saw
Jimmy G making steak the other day
really good yeah beautiful band though I
don't know about his footballs but
anyway so we all caught up yes we're
caught up I know that so now that we've
gotten to all the catch up and all that
good stuff and what the Lord's have been
playing we have a guests that's been
very patient we gotta switch on Focus to
Lord Alex's video game system history no
his yes
legendary Press Start podcast run and of
course what led him to creating the
entire entertaining and super
informative oh no it's Alex YouTube
channel so Alexis start from the very
beginning what would have some of the
first video game systems yet or PCS and
what got you into gaming uh I had a NES
when I was six years old in 1989 I
started I had a little brother you know
like my other brother was coming
like oh let's give them something to
entertaining while we take care of the
new one so I got an NES and it just
started from there oh give me some games
with that and yes that you had brother I
had the one with the trackpad and the
and the gun so I had the triple pack
okay so he had he's the second person
that said they had the the trackpad yeah
I had to track back the gun in the game
so I had duck hunt Mario and the the
track game the track
and field yeah all in one in one cart
yeah so I had that for like three years
because we were poor and then uh then I
had a couple of games after that RBI
Baseball was a big one oh soft do we
co-sign and we definitely co-signed rbl
baseball was a tough game yeah and then
just like after that I got into Super
Nintendo and then it was from there it
was like Chrono Trigger Final Fantasy
three two no two or three
the Batman Returns for SNES yeah I was
Konami okay
yeah it's kind of crazy considering
working armies came from yeah and where
they are now because it could not be
track and field back in the day too yep
I believe so I think so I believe so
then after that Sony and
which Doom
one oh yeah
all right
so wait we got you skipped a little bit
so okay it is I get the situation you
know what I'm saying a lot of console
stuff like that but that Super NES which
was still impressive so at that point
like how did the console I mean how did
the PC situation emerge like how did
that happen so it was my mom got a new
job we needed a computer okay
because she needed a new job and I was
like
what should I wear and so my boys they
were like yo check out this three and a
half floppy disk you're gonna love it I
was like all right let's go so I popped
do man I was like what like 11. oh and I
was playing Doom
how many how many three and a half
floppy dicks this was Doom thing
I think sure it was like five yeah like
the whole game was like 10 or 12. yeah
and then after that it was and then I
got into like Diablo one and like all
those other weird PC games and then when
I turned 13.
it was quick
Oh you talked about that and a lot of
people don't understand the impact Quake
had on the video card uh you know genre
when the video card started coming out
you know like 3D effects and all that
other stuff to actually get stuff to run
Quake because Quake was that thing oh I
want to be okay I got a p13
never hear of Trent resident or Nine
Inch Nails
play Quake at 2 A.M with like old Sony
headphones on
with Trent rezner making the soundtrack
hi hello uh you're damaged your entire
life
no and so I mean after that it was it
just went from there Diablo two Deus Ex
Deus Ex is probably one of my favorite
games of all time
um I mean if you want to go back and
like do conspiracy stuff if you play
Deus Ex today you'll just lose it like
you'll be like I cannot believe it
um and then I got into uh like PS I was
like oh PlayStation PS1 and 64. like we
were doing better financially so I was
mowing lawns too so I was having some
side money hustling and so I started
getting I started doing both the PC and
console so I had N64 PS1 for Final
Fantasy VII
um you started playing all those games
there and then I got a side job where
you can only work like two hours a day
because you were a minor yeah you know
so one of those things
I have uh the card remember the card
yeah
I hear all your history so far and I
don't hear any Sega
every year what's up so uh okay
um Sonic sucks oh no not like this Sonic
Sonic is a bad game
uh Sega had final fight which is pretty
good enough
yes so I mean there really wasn't
anything much on Sega that I wanted to
play okay
good games were on Super Nintendo
Fanboy and his kids back then continue
what you said was like like all of us we
picked the side we picked the sign you
know like financially because
financially you know like me you were
you know you didn't have much you know
cash so that's why you just you know
this is where I rock with
um and that's that's cool that's what
everybody did they do it right now
he's gonna try and set me up you see
this
actually actually
he being nice right now
what you did was back then you actually
had real life friends exactly yeah
that's my next question you had you had
real life friends where you were like oh
you got a Sega Genesis I got a Super
Nintendo Friday night let's hang out
with my stuff Mountain Dews Little
Caesars Pizza thank you
my friends who had a Genesis that told
you Nintendo sucked but you had to go
over there and try his Genesis and he
had to go play a Nintendo so that was
your best but that you know you did that
with I had a a buddy um
God [ __ ] his name was George when we
were when I moved when I lived in one
area oh wait a second and then and then
I moved to another area and it was it
was Marcus so me and Marcus was like a
lot of like our like middle school stuff
and then High School Marcus moved and
then I had like some other friends that
I met in high school and that's when we
got really into PC gaming even more
gotcha and then we're doing that even
more so Marcus couldn't had didn't have
a computer but we were we play console
games all together oh good respect so we
always had a like a lean like one person
to have like a turbo Graphics another
person have a Genesis oh it's not what
platform that we're gonna rock on so
yeah it's cool yeah it's it's everybody
bought a different one yeah yeah that's
how we did but that was the culture back
then because it was like you said Alex
it was one of those things like you said
again if you didn't have it your man had
it but you could go over to his house
and yeah check it out you know say oh
you swap or you trade and stuff like
that it was just a different time as
opposed to like yo I'm not even you know
dealing with this person because
we didn't stare at our phones all day
and not make friends and there you go
there you go respectively respectfully
no doubt how many followers you had
it's a follower account so at this point
now you do I get you doing both you got
the PCS you still got now money's in a
situation consoles are coming through
you've been mentioned some amazing
PlayStation games there's still one
place to get recruited mention yet that
I'm surprised that I felt that you had
influence but you went from went from
Psalm PS1 PS2 that kind of thing they
kind of did both PC gaming and console
gaming yeah okay
because when because when I turned 17
and I played Metal Gear Solid 2 for the
first time there we go I was waiting for
this I didn't I didn't understand at all
and I thought and I was like I hate this
game and then
and I was like I don't understand the
ending this is weird and then I I was
like all right let me play it again when
I'm like 23 and 9 11 happened and I was
like oh let me play it again because I'm
bored there's nothing to play and then
I'm at the end of the game and I'm like
this yes
and then go back and then play Metal
Gear Solid 2 again now yeah
play it now and see what happens and
it's like oh hello hi because she was a
prophet and then how about this play
death stranding now
I need to play defshire
[Laughter]
during lockdown and you didn't play
death stranding and you didn't see how
far ahead Kojima was
help me help me Alex would be a law on
that because I'm struggling with the
FedEx notion help me
get rid of my bias towards that aspect
and why is it so engrossing to you
best training is is one of the most
relaxing yet stressful games I've ever
played
so you can be like oh you're just
delivering packages this is stupid but
then like when it's not about the
packages that are being delivered it's
about like the stories that are
happening in between those people that
need those specific things gotcha
and so you're like and so what it is is
what you're trying so if you haven't
played death stranding I'll give you
guys a quick rundown there are there's
an individual there's an invisible
threat right that is that is killing
people into the world and no one is
allowed outside because it will kill
them oh okay so I know what he doing
okay gotcha okay hello gotcha welcome to
2020. wow um so what happens is because
people are not allowed outside it's
become more like you need to get people
to deliver these things called porter so
you can survive gotcha right people are
now segregated from each other they
cannot communicate and they're stuck in
their own little communities with their
own little thoughts and ideologies so
what you're doing is you are now
connecting every single Community
together to rebuild the United States
got it oh okay say lessons
like we meet you at the press conference
because that was an eloquent explanation
to actually entice people to play it so
and so the thing is like I'm very
against like I wouldn't say against I I
do not like ham-fisted political
messages in my games okay
I like if you're gonna have a political
message I think it should be nuanced and
up to the player to decide what that
message is and how they interpret it
right which is why I love kojima's game
so much because you can be like nuclear
war is nuclear arms are bad okay uh yeah
if you're basic right but like you can
dig deeper into like the military
industrial complex like how like what
else happened like all this other stuff
like actual you know pmcs probably
military corporations for him it's like
it's all this kind of stuff that you can
dig into because he layers everything
but we're just stranding like you're
sitting there and you realize how
important this medicine or this thing is
to this person and then you're walking
it and you're like if you screw up when
you're walking it either because you
didn't use the balance or you didn't
lose focus or going down the wrong area
or you tried to do a shortcut and you
damage it and you're like right and so
like then you give it to them and
they're like yo it's broken why did you
do this like you know but then like it
gets of course it goes full Kojima of
course and it gets crazy and that's but
that's like the good [ __ ] right like
that's when you start seeing I'm sorry
the good stuff that's we start seeing
like
everything sort of like start to stack
up
there's a layer there's a layer of like
basic human interaction then there's the
the political interaction then there's
the emotional aspect and now we're going
full science crazy town because then
he's like hey did you take your LSD yet
okay take it now here's a three-hour
ending
[Laughter]
the ending cutscene is three hours Jesus
okay all right I'll say less but it's
awesome
they're killing me on LSM and it's in
Game Pass for PC so I got I got no
excuses I think I think it's a great
game you should definitely play it with
the lights off and with a pair of
headphones on okay fair enough and so
again to be in the mood for it yeah I'm
definitely gonna do it so we got that
got all the consoles did so at that
point now it's just everything every
console that comes out subsequently then
you still pick up all this stuff that
you just say eh I'm sticking with PC I I
think I stopped gaming on PC I started
getting on console near the middle of
the 360. oh okay okay my brother had a
360.
um so we shared that in the house and so
Halo was like a big thing for me so I
played Halo a lot nice I gotta I got all
the achievements on Halo 3 ODST and
reach I got every single one
um and then I was like why am I paying
for online yep
that part I was because my little
brother couldn't afford it so I'm
footing the bill and I'm like what is
this
what is this I love it like like I play
Warcraft I don't get charged to play to
charge you know like work at that 15
bucks a month but it's like
even then I was like why am I paying for
that too yeah yeah
I was like that should be free like why
like am I giving you 60 bucks and then
maybe a monthly sub how about time out
time out we're not gonna go past
Warcraft oh
we're gonna stop here for a second all
right here we go what is the warrior
what I mean what was your character
uh
um how long did you play for and what
made you stop and what made you start I
played all the way through Lich King
whoa wow
yeah I played all the way through Lich
King when my classic well now in classic
I was SM ruin on my lock and then I was
uh full Affliction in TBC and then full
Affliction again in Wrath of Lich King I
had to stop because I was in college
okay
and I started because I've always loved
Warcraft and blizzard games and I and
now
I yell at blizzard and I curse at them
all the time
because I love their games and I'm like
blizzard yeah you know that's literally
what it is so like
I I hate what they did with Diablo
Immortal I hate what they do with
OverWatch too I hate what they did I'm
I'm very worried about Diablo 4. Diablo
3 was an absolute trash fire
um
it was just real bad so like blizzard
games have always loved uh but yeah
colleges would stop me from from a while
because I was not passing classes it was
effective yeah we heard about this game
with the
effects it's bad it's bad yeah you know
I was like I'm paying for all this stuff
and then I was and then steam started
getting a lot better and I was like yeah
I'm just gonna play CS go
and you're right from a financial
standpoint when you're over there you
see the disparity and you see like okay
why am I technically doing that and it
totally makes sense so you got all this
you got this gaming experience and stuff
like that but I want to transition now
from the content creation standpoint and
I wanted to say like you know what made
you say okay either a I want to be a
content creator or be kind of what maybe
LED you to press start or like how did
that start for you
um
I
I was like oh uh well really it was I
made a I had a YouTube account whatever
I never really used it I just watched
for the people do it and I was like
I would see like
people really saying really dumb things
on the internet about games
and I was like why do these journalists
I was like well at that time gamergate
was really big oh
okay
gamergate was really big and it was like
I was like why does kataku even exist
s
[Music]
do you tell oh it's like I was like this
website made an article about watermelon
butts what the hell are you doing how
are you a Gaming website what what
actual like
I wouldn't say clout but like what makes
you an authority to talk about video
games with everything you talk about is
always the worst possible thing about a
video game and not even about the game
at all and then I would see those things
like that I would see
I have some friends at IGN I'm not going
to throw them under the bus but like
there were some articles written in
other bigger websites that just did not
make any sense game scores didn't make
sense
um a seven is not an average score it
should be a five just because you got
family in the middle screaming out yeah
yeah so uh common sense right um
You can actually no actually you should
go to uh level level one gaming
okay
after you go to Lords of gaming.net then
you can go to
salute the face
so I I was just like all right let me
just throw my spin on it whatever and I
just did a lot of of course really bad
webcam videos really bad lighting really
bad audio yeah
um and it never really you know it
didn't take off I had like four views
five views whatever and then
three years ago I was like I was
transitioning between
um just like between homes and stuff I
bought a house yeah and I was like let
me just stream for the hell of it I'm
bored I got nothing to do so I started
streaming the entire Metal Gear Solid
series
and people started watching that mm-hmm
and then I started streaming all the
Resident Evil series and I was doing
like I started going through every all
the games and then I would just set up
once too dude I did all the God of War
ones
[Music]
now this is annoying me now I'm annoyed
like both of y'all like with these
similar takes now like what is going on
let me bring it down bring it down let
me hear it I think 2018 completely
ignores the entire facet of what made
Kratos human in the first place and the
fact that even in the PSP games you had
such a huge amount of humanity in Kratos
even into even in everything else and
even I mean everybody was just like oh
he's just angry I'm like do you know why
he's saying yeah there's literally
there's literally a part in one of the
God of Wars where you have to defend
your family and the only way to give
them health is to give help from you to
give to them but yeah and and so like is
it the entire concept of like I keep
saying like a lot but the entire concept
of a lot of journalists and reviewers
playing these games not playing The
Originals and then only talking about
Kratos from and from like an outsider
perspective that do not know the lore in
the history and then saying oh this is
the best God of War ever we haven't
played the other ones how can you say
that thank you right and and so it just
I think it just it's I think it's
insulting that people will only talk
about 2018 but they don't talk about two
three of the PSP games I'm gonna tell
you right now I'ma honestly tell you
right now you can do no wrong from this
thing
yeah God of War 3 might be one of the
best action like
packed adventure games that's ever
existed I think good
it's just it's crazy like and obviously
God will wanted to need a lot of uh
props because they couldn't have done
the stuff they did in three because they
have to do a lot of story building
because everything was already done at
that point so it's just like they
literally went started God of War 3 with
like just straight to the wall like it
was it was crazy well it three started
right where two ended yeah yeah
Olympus and he was like I'm coming yep
yeah you know and so like I think in in
battling many gods instead of just one
yeah dude over and over and not today
it's the same troll like I'm saying same
troll in different colors what's his
name and uh I forgot see I forgot that
character's name
yeah Boulder yeah same thing I mean look
I'll give I'll give you this great voice
acting yes beautiful phenomenal voice
acting in 2018. movies pretty sure
um but 2018 did not invent the what cut
the one cut camera you know who did Dead
Space one that's who did it everybody
talks about 2018 is like oh there's only
one shot hello hi Dead Space
you just lost points with King right
there
no no no no no no no no he lost
absolutely no points at all sir yeah I
mean you can do this is like I think
what it is too is I think
it God of War 2018
was a victim of being of being made for
the system that was probably their most
popular one of their most popular at the
time
it's just like I feel like PlayStation 2
and Playstation 3 was definitely at a
height for PlayStation but I feel like
the PS4 was more mainstream than those
other platforms because there's there's
a reason there's a lot of people that's
never playing
the large part I think also too like
Uncharted effect and Last of Us is the
effect the last of us has impacted a lot
of Sony games yeah I agree we call a
glass of this effect the last thing I
want PlayStation 2 back
getting it back
that's what I want back like when they
dissolve Japan Studio I was like oh okay
oh yeah do you understand my frustration
now do you do get my frustration
everything you just said you want the
PlayStation too those dudes back you
want those guys back I want those guys
it's not happening right and and my
frustration is every day I see it and
it's a constant reminder every week when
I come to pick up a topic every week
they throw something in my face and say
you'll never get us back baby yeah they
get further and further away from it
every day and especially you know I I
really viable Alex says about like you
know a lot of the media and certain
influencers because like especially with
Sony like it's no it's no secret that
like Sony will Blacklist you if you if
you talk negative about their game I
have no problem doing it at all oh
Counter-Strike is bad he said only these
hip to the edge Lords and Alex people
have General disdain for Sony talk like
this
that's exactly let me tell you a little
game let me tell you about another game
called DOTA 2.
oh man anyway I'm sorry and I was gonna
say like you know when you see stuff
like that that's why it's hard to know
who's saying stuff for relationships
Hussein stuff for sponsorships like it's
the influencer road in the in the media
Road it's it's it's really it's really
rough like I mean I think I think you
have to be able to find somebody that
you like their reviews
and you have to like okay they have
similar tastes that yeah I have there
you go and so therefore that's what I'm
gonna watch like it's really funny how
donkey literally says I don't like jrpgs
when he does a review of a 200 hour jrpg
in three minutes it's literally all just
memes and people get angry at him like
what do you what do you expect bro like
what do you I love I love when ducky
reviewed it was two of the Pokemon games
and one was trash talking and he
reviewed the other Pokemon game and he
was doing nothing but positive talking
yeah yeah it's a good point I mean at
the end of the day like kind of going to
the influencers or the reviewers that
you know kind of either share similar
interests or have experience in the
genre and then you know kind of making
your informed opinion on that so you
watching all this stuff Lauren Alex is
getting kind of upset you know not
liking what he sees out there streaming
okay and then I I jumped on Twitter and
it worked so I would make like so I was
like you know what 2020.
we're all at home
I was like I think it was like December
November I was like you know what I'm
gonna dedicate this I'm gonna do a video
every single day
I was like that so like I I weight lift
a lot and it's like you have to be
consistent to be successful so I was
like even though everybody says you
don't have to do a video every day so I
was like no I'm doing a video every
single day and it was just like I would
improve every single video whether it's
a little bit or a lot and then it would
just start stacking and stacking and
stacking and everybody was like and then
what I did was I just deleted all the
old videos that I didn't like because I
was like oh they're trash
videos and then and I was like and then
the the anniversary for total biscuit
passed by and I was like I was thinking
to myself I was like you know I have
haven't seen a single PC Board review
since TB passed and then I was very
hesitant about doing that because what I
didn't want to do is step on his legacy
gotcha and so I was very like okay
how do I do this but not like respect it
so if a viewer of total biscuit from the
past watches this content they're not
like oh you just [ __ ] you're just
stealing it so I added his
so I'm like this is an homage to him
because if it wasn't for him I wouldn't
be doing this one I love this stuff goes
back respect that looks so good and so I
started doing that and that like I think
I did it with one and it got like 25 000
views
and then
um
and then the Unreal Engine 5 demo
happens oh yeah oh yeah the girl flying
in the canyon or whatever flying in the
canyon and every single [ __ ] was on
Twitter talking about io's throughput
and ssds
only Possible only possible so I was
like I was like you know what we're
gonna have some fun I made a video about
it and that was the first salt video
that I made
and that one today let me see if I can
find it um I'll remember that at that
time
oh yeah certain partnership was
announced prior to that that one today
right now yeah so that one is May 27
2021
that video as of today has 42 000 years
so I was like all right that was a
one-off whatever that's not gonna happen
again and then next Thursday something
happened
and then the Thursday after that
the Thursday after that
then the Thursday oh yeah oh yeah it was
like I was like why is this happening
every Thursday and so now I'm like wait
every single Thursday these clowns
go crazy so now if you follow me on
Twitter oh you see with that little
video I post
or it's Ryan gossing like hey it's just
another Thursday
so which then leads me to the next
question which is the evolution of that
and which I see well personally with
really
your channel really starts to take shape
it's the it's the Twitter comments and
and and the salt accumulation so let's
get into that and one thing I really
respect about you is that again you are
able to turn the emotionality of an
extreme subset of Gamers and use it to
humor yourself and also benefit your
channel which I think is Jesus which is
absolute Jesus so what I want and The
Comebacks the the integration with with
the with the pop culture stuff it's
absolutely hilarious so like how did
that get started specifically
um so I don't do a script oh it's off
the top oh everything is off the top
okay and
so my wife heard me screaming one day
and she's like what are you saying
and I was like well I'm insulting people
she goes you're really good at that yes
so out so I was like whatever and then
one night like I was editing and then
one night I was
um let's say how do I put this but you
don't lose support or oh okay okay thank
you for respect
I want to say this in the right way I
was I was imbibing from
the I was imbibing myself from the
goodness of Mother Earth yes
all right yes yes I get the connection
yeah go ahead I'm there I'm there and
and I was doing that as I was editing
and I was watching Aqua Teen Hunger
Force okay oh my God okay
so
and so I was like wait this one scene
matches exactly what is happening and so
what I started doing was I was Finding
clips of like funny shows I watch or
funny things happening or memes and
stuff and I was like What if I just add
these memes after every Twitter post and
then it just started coming together and
so now like what's great is it it was
all an accident like the video now has a
Cadence right so you're like okay here
comes the beginning here comes the meme
here comes the reaction yes now so like
it it comes like it's like a wave right
so you're not getting bombarded all the
time and you can watch the video longer
because there's spaces in between me
going nuts right and so that's that's
how I built it and I was like okay
there's a down time now there's now
we're climbing there's the peak all
right there's a down time again and so
now you can just like so you keep
watching and it just it just stuck yes
and so now what happens is like I've
I've amassed a folder of memes that's
like over a gigabyte
just to kick a bit of memes and so you
know it and so now it's it's like okay
what am I gonna do about this week or
stuff like that and even nothing pops
off this week I can always find a video
from someone that I can react to yes
yeah and then just kind of do that thing
or we'll do something else but there's
always a fanboy doing something by
Thursday yeah but Thursday is lit
usually I get my my stuff by probably
Tuesday and I'll do some Fanboys stuff
by like around Wednesday Thursday so you
can always just like look at my timeline
to have them so so that beer that you
get this content right that's fueling
this my question is like for me when I
watch it the one of the more hilarious
things is that when something discussed
you to that point when we get the backup
when the backup starts going down here
then I know it's coming right so then I
want to talk about the backup
to the time slap it did okay how did we
get there let's go okay so so what I did
was what I used to do was when something
really crazy would happen I I wear
basketball I worked not basketball
shorts but I wore like sports shorts
right
and they crawl up my legs
they just crawl up and so I would start
backing up in the chair and then people
were like
is he wearing underwear
look they were like look how big his
legs are just saying stuff like that to
me the comments in the comment section
yes and I was like I was like you know
what oh and then one day I was like What
if I just go with it I just backed up
and I was like is this what you want
I'm done give it to people what they're
white that's what it is you know and
then I just kept going with the with the
Affleck thing and then I just kept doing
and so now like the like the memes just
come and then they just start growing
and then the people that watch me start
getting like my sense of humor and then
they just start feeding into it and then
I'm feeding it back and it just becomes
like a lot like addicts on my stream and
my stream is out of hand yeah
are out of absolutely insane and I have
a soundboard and and like and I start
stuff they have so like there was one
guy who was saying some really uh uncool
things
about the LGBT community and then
um I played you guys saw that song
Ricardo you got that so you guys know
Ricardo probably heard it but I don't
know I'm gonna I'm gonna find it right
now so so type so you're gonna get out
you're gonna get a naked man dancing
he's gonna do that
so just so if so so so do you know what
I'll find it for you and you can play it
I'll find you the anime one where's the
Ricardo what lay it on there what's the
context behind Ricardo so
Ricardo it was was a meme
that happened like a bunch of years ago
and it was just a guy
it was just a guy dancing yeah I see is
the race this the red bandana thing
situation that one is there like a chat
that I can put it in I can give you the
uh yeah yeah yeah here we go here we go
here here's the one
yes yes yes
moving on continue
and so what I did was I got a 50
donation when that happened right and
then I had to take my shirt off so I
played that song
and I took my shirt off and then I was
screaming I'll see you at Pride
so now my chat like when I show up
they're just like just like Pride flags
and stuff even though like and what's
funny is like everybody
like I apparently cross lines yes people
on the right people left whatever and
then there's people that are like hey
look I'm right wing and I'm not gay but
you're making me gay
listen the conflict is good it's
bringing people together so you know
it's it's and because I don't do
political stuff I don't do anything like
that and it's just I just try to keep it
fun and light and everybody likes that
because there's no like I don't have to
hear this [ __ ] again yeah no it's Sunday
it's good and the reason why I want to
give you your props because again at the
end of the day what I what I respect
about you is that it's not a personal
attack right it's a systematic breakdown
of what someone else said right yeah and
then just to educate them okay you're
being emotional this is what's going on
here this is why what you're saying is
incorrect and I'm gonna show you and I'm
gonna have fun with you attack you
attack the logic right not the person
that's what I try to do deal with satire
any any longer you know so and then when
you tell the truth people can't deal
with that as well yeah so you got sad
time you got truth then and also let's
be real like a lot of the a lot of
people box themselves in with the goal
post moving and the absolute statements
right so then now when it comes back you
start to see the shift in it it's just
it's a process but if you just love
games and not celebrate and worship
things the way certain people worship
things then you wouldn't be in that
situation it just kind of yeah it's
literally the the idea of forgiving a
multi-billion or trillion dollar
Corporation because you like the logo on
a box and that's like that's where I get
I'm just like I think to myself I'm like
how do you sit there all day
and you just yeah I'm trying I'm trying
to find the right ways no no no no but
what it is is
what it is is bad faith arguments right
yeah well you sit there all day on
Twitter and you gargle the cockles of a
company that does not care about you
they do not know you exist you are a
number or like I say to my videos your
wallet to be goatseed
yeah
and that you know and I'm just like how
do you how do you how do you accept that
as like a human being like look for and
so I keep I'm like this to me is just
it's wild and so I'm just like all right
look I'm not gonna insult you personally
because I don't know who you are right
right you don't know me I'm gonna just
take your argument make it look like a
[ __ ] and just I mean I think I've been
blocked by
um two people Xbox University blocked me
I put him in the video he got real mad
um
[Laughter]
no one was safe had somebody hit me up
and was like yo
you gotta check this dude so I said what
check what dude so I said um send it to
me so they sent it to me then I watched
it I was like that was kind of funny
I said that's not funny
I go freaking for the streets
he was right in the chat like the next
day we bought we going ripping with each
other in a live chat and it was all love
and it wasn't disrespectful it wasn't
mean it wasn't disrespectful so like
when I looked at it it wasn't
mean-spirited so I'm like whatever yeah
so you know um and I gotta address it in
my form and have my little minions go
attack you
what do you mean like all two of them
the two that blocked you
[Laughter]
know I could just like log out of
Twitter
you have to you have to get your minions
in check King how are you gonna have
your mittens blocked and they can't
attack him if they blocked
salute to you on that I do want to ask
real quick because I know we go you got
some legendary history that we didn't
touch and I can't believe somebody said
the legendary Press Start podcast run
man you shout out to coldfield we've had
all the cars got excited you don't say
shout out to JB youtube.com that's good
gaming yes yes and then of course lady
Eric has a red part original crew as
well I I do want to get the a quick
origin story uh just about that because
that was a huge part of yesterday I do
also how I found you honestly to be
honest with you so I just wanted to talk
about that like how did that get started
um I so I met solid rev and I met Blaze
4K the homies
that he had and I was like whatever
we'll do it and then Kofi was on that
same podcast with me
and solid red okay okay and so Kofi was
like I'm building a podcast I need a PC
guy and I was like oh okay got it got it
it makes sense and so he wanted to grab
one person of every type of field and he
so he we got everybody there and then
that that took off there
um Eric I had to leave for other reasons
and stuff like that too and then we kept
going and then you know just real life
happened and we had to stop
unfortunately and but it was it was a
tough five years
they're awesome I want to give you all
y'all flowers because like I remember
when we started and we used to talk we
were like yo Presto I got good podcast
man like that is we we always said that
like you know people have different
veins a different podcasts but like
Press Start was like the more like rated
R version of our podcast like the good
chemistry
yes that was a spice
that was debate Alex that was pull up
for you Alex that was yeah it was it was
a spicy time when I debated dealer yes
yes yes I remember that
it was a spicy time back in the day but
it was just fun like it says that like I
respect the chemistry you had fun great
group you know and I definitely wanted
to give y'all flowers because I I was
surprised like oh man that was
definitely one of the good ones because
it's hard to do this thing consistently
it's not easy it's not easy because
people think you just pop in and that's
all it is like every week you just start
a show yeah okay is what that's a crazy
run and then now to see you try to start
a show and have nobody watch yeah yeah
absolutely yeah that's true too which is
what happens that's exactly what happens
you know but like Kofi was always trying
to improve something Jay Maine was
always working on things in the
background you know Jack always Jack was
always working whether he's streaming or
doing something Erica same thing so it
was really awesome and so like
support the channels Jay Maine yes
for the win yes yeah and good game
because Kobe is actually putting out
good content yeah salute them sold that
and then obviously the transitioning you
and what you doing right now it's good
to see you shining out there we get the
fast laps we get that my exclusive
quality we get all
the catchphrases I hear that man it like
like what's funny is I think Jim Ryan
was hanging out in the spaces
he was like oh you'll pay a thousand
dollars for a console I got you
that is hilarious
serving them up to me oh yeah
for Lord Alex's history I do segment be
an addict started how do you first hear
about ILP or carbon contact with our
content I was always curious about that
it was addict that attic was on PSP and
then we were talking about RPGs and then
we started playing Divinity original
together
and then I just watched you guys from
there
and of course the question we have to
ask all the guests in the realm I need
Lloyd Alex's top five video games or
franchises of all time
uh Metal Gear Solid Deus Ex Chrono
Trigger
he's saying that fast very strong stuff
I'm gonna have to say Sonic
hell no
wait three okay okay okay because I
wanted to throw one of those in there
and Diablo 2.0
Legendary list and the final question
which would be interesting for you
because your PC guy favorite console or
uh
uh I don't want let's go
I want Nvidia to burn and never make a
video card again
so no way video okay I think I think I
think Jensen is one of the worst people
that you could actually have in that
board to actually sit there and sell
products to people he thinks that the
mining crash didn't happen and so I you
know I hope
I hope I hope he reaps what he sows
um
favorite console um
God it's just it's a tie between SNES
and PS1
PS2 is close behind
but SNES and PS1 they're like right
there I I really wish that we had
Twitter during then the N64 PS1 era oh
because both of those consoles had
bangers okay okay fair enough that would
have been that would have been amazing I
mean we had AOL and antagonist gaming on
America online I don't know if you guys
are that old oh yeah oh yeah all right
yes one SNES okay salute salute
tremendous game in history if you're
hanging out we got more stuff to talk
about with these topics man no doubt the
legendary Alex in the building so I'm
gonna get the poll going on while you
were crew up the super chats okay so I
have over
740 people in my house yeah you didn't
ring the doorbell you didn't wipe your
feet
hit the like thumbs up
she said how rude anyway so I'll get the
poll from last week supposedly people
spoken with the recent rumors regarding
a potential Halo infinite engine change
to Unreal if true what do you think
should be the best course of action for
343 moving forward the winner of our
four-way IOP poll where they're kind of
very competitive 38 eight percent of the
vote was pull the plug on Halo infinite
to work on a new Unreal Engine 5 Halo
game coming in at second place razor
close because 38 was the first 35
launch Battle Royale mode and Unreal
Engine 5 to buy more time for the
transition to Halo infinite group I
think that's what they're going to do to
be honest with you in third place at 14
of the vote stay with the slip space
engine changing engines at this stage
makes no sense and in last place with 10
percent of the vote was the messy Lords
I don't care what engine they use until
somebody explained what happened to
Spartan a lot
why is everybody in that entire poll
wrong oh break it down I'll go let's get
let's hear about unreal your objections
the people went unreal would you use a
an engine that is not proven
Unreal Engine 4 has some of the worst
Shader caching stutters you could
possibly find that no matter what kind
of horsepower you get you're going to
get a frame stutter on a competitive FPS
shooter by the way you literally have
one of the best engines ever made with
idtech on your doors in your house
okay
and you're not going to use idtech so
your thought processes obviously it's
intact with the Bethesda acquisition
um what about the question in reference
to contractor and familiarity kind of
with engines being that like slip what
because you know what slip space but but
pretty much that would be zMAX or
somebody for Bethesda pretty much did
take it over 340. so you would you would
rather that route
I would rather Hugo Martin
take that series the guy who did Doom
okay 2016. so you want them to hand it
over take that's I want you to go
because if you're looking at okay let me
take one of the most iconic first person
shooters ever made the game that made
first person shooters which is Doom let
me take that which is so beloved and
figure out a way to actually make it
modern for a new audience and also keep
the people that played in the beginning
happy the guy did The Impossible yeah
with doom yep he literally said you're
not hiding behind cover the way you get
health now is you keep killing more
welcome to Doom you know like and that
was Doom back then and so if you're
going to sit there and say how do I take
a series that is beloved by so many
people and then turn it around and make
it for a new audience to be captured by
and actually give good gameplay Hugo
Martin would be the he is the Yoshi P of
first-person shooters the ocp save Final
Fantasy 16 a 14 I'm sorry 14. Hugo would
definitely save this because there's no
reason around it there's no Rhyme or
Reason so you think you can save it
you think you could save it without
changing the core because that's the
beef right the beef is that that you
give it to the creator of Doom and he
doomifies it instead of weeping a Halo
well that's the thing that's the worry
that I guess that is the worry out there
right that you take it away from the
people that over the years that have
learned how to make the Halo that people
expect them to make right right and
that's in line with old Halo and you
give it to the guy that it's never made
Halo made games of generally in that elk
first person shooters and you were the
worry is okay it's not going to be Halo
anymore it's going to be with three four
three who never made a Halo before yeah
yeah but then and look what happened
they did have some budgie it was a lot
of remnants Mark Mark who cleaned the
locker room oh damn
Calvin who was at the gate I think my
thing is you mean the fact that they had
they had
four Halo games to put into a Master
Chief Collection that could have been
done in a week and it took them three
years to fix it and you're like oh what
if they do them if I Halo shut up
what about what are you talking about
I'm sorry I'm sorry it took them three
games to actually get a Halo that
actually felt good to play and now is
when they do it and they still can't
figure it out and you're worried about
ID doing something that Halo I hope they
do
I think my biggest thing would be is you
know maybe I know about this oh
perfectly I think the Doom Community
wouldn't be as spoiled and entitled that
the Halo Community is because like 343
did attempt to do stuff in Halo 5 to
like balance out the old and new but
then they they backtracked it all
because like the Halo Community like had
them like bad over it like they did a
little stuff like if you're running your
shows don't recover uh so they demanded
you to like confront people uh they did
like the when you shoot you you get shot
out of um
out of ads so like I I understand where
you're coming from Alex but I think that
Halo Community for the most part like
the core audience like I don't I don't
know if you could make changes that's
going to entice new people to join but
also keep them people happy because it's
just like how the core of Hill infinite
actually plays like old Halo and
everybody liked it um
that's a dumb argument right because
because three four three I'm sorry three
four three actually went in and they
took them four and five to make a Halo
and during four and five they completely
went away from what made Halo great in
the first place adding ads and Sprint
and all this other garbage they try to
make it like Call of Duty so you can't
sit here and tell me oh they're going to
do them a fight when they made it Cod
into Halo basically in four and five
well no I'm just saying there's people
in the chat and then you're sitting here
saying okay well now 343 finally got the
mechanics right in the Halo now there's
an actual five shot but the thing is now
we have a Commando rifle that makes no
sense they should have been the DMR in
the first place and now we're adding a
DMR into the mix on top of that two
years later hi what for why when you
could have just made the commander with
the DMR and not balance around another
weapon like the decisions they're making
don't make sense I agree Halo in the
first place and then they go through and
they threw away all the Legacy Halo
content to make their own stand no
you're standing on the shoulders of
giants when you talk about Halo and
bungee yes so don't sit there and tell
me that you're better than them that
you're going to try and do your own spin
the thing is at least Hugo Martin would
actually go in and say what made Halo
great in the first place just like what
made do great in the first place and how
do we adapt that and keep this the core
still there the gameplay of Halo
infinite is good I'm not going to say
it's not the problem is it's like it's
like trying to get a like a one carat
diamond around a giant pile of dog feces
I think the issue too is that it's it's
two-part one when you say a tech which
is phenomenal tech and and your man the
problem is we have to have resources and
both sides agree right to be able to to
take that project and then the second
thing is with to your point where they
got the slip space to at least to play
like a decent Halo game from a campaign
in a multiplayer perspective the issue
then becomes why can't they deliver the
content and it seems evident that with
some space they the tooling they seem to
can't be able to deliver it in a timely
fashion and thus they're in the
situation they are the question is if
they do unreal which would be
interesting right does that help their
contractor situation because we know a
lot they got like a ton of contractors
coming in there so I'm very curious
about that but yeah I see your point a
lot of people have said I don't love
contractors a lot I know but that seems
how the 341 pure workers I want the
people that actually want to make a Halo
game making a Halo game right that's an
infrastructure issue that that is the
way they're set up and that's a bigger
and I don't even I don't even think to
be honest with you we had Crystal
Dynamics and um boom somebody came in
stolen while we were sleeping uh talking
to Activision and blizzard so we have to
wait until this deal gets done and then
we can go over there and still uh
Crystal Dynamics back and then we can
actually take those workers and have
those workers work and fix things and
stuff you've got like on like honestly I
think what they should really do is what
what Chris Reagan said is just basically
pull the plug on Halo infinite and then
just relaunch the game that that's
you're gonna do that I like when it
comes that's honestly yeah
I don't know because you if you do that
that means you the plan is to stick to
it and I think they made the decision
not to stick to it yeah yeah they got
the copyright for what the endless right
right
what do you mean by did not see I'm
sorry well yeah it's the thing like if
they've made the decision I think to to
to not stick to it and move on
so it's like shutting it down and
relaunching it is it's what you would
want to do if you wanted to save it I
don't think at this point they want to
save it you're telling me that Microsoft
is going to abandon one of their largest
IPS
series
and the game as a service for a couple
of seasons and then move on as opposed
to this 10-year plan that they had now
that which
potentially could happen
possibilities
yeah anyway move on because we went
crazy we went crazy
but anyway sorry we had a Super Chat let
me get this topic sir yeah I'm gonna get
this uh get some water yeah
casares three dollars so we chat pop
making me feel like I'm in the aliens
movie
that might have lost that reference yeah
then we got Danny passion official
so he's the official daddy yours just
saying hello and asking uh to chat
asking the chat to hit the up to get me
exactly thank you hit the like hit that
like hit that like hit that like share
it up and we got game 814 remember for
34 months football season is killing me
but my Patriots are crushing the Detroit
Lions so I'll spend some time with you
guys oh and oh as always hey King Boo
Boo hey Forte hey Forte by the way
um I see you made attic uh camera look
fantastic right so what I need you to do
since me and you are best buds right
hook a brother up I actually actually
try uh when I messaged you yesterday
asking was you busy and you said you was
out with the fam I was gonna see if you
wanted to jump in that call when I was
doing it yeah yo so I text you I text
you back and this is literally what I
said I said are you okay yeah you left
me on scene
so like if if if this is his only
message to get to me are you up excuse
me are you up
and I'm like yo with the wife are you
okay you're supposed to say yes right
yes I'm good I'm okay because
I'm thinking if I didn't see you pop on
um on um XBox Live
then I'd have probably called you no I
feel like oh I saw you popped on I was
like oh he's like that he's alive
all right then we have dude it's not
black Harry Potter
no doubt we're immediately waiting for
this uh Volare iron Lord pillow link it
will be it is going down either during
the week or by next weekend it will be
live so that's next weekend we'll have
the link up for you the page and and the
pricing and stuff like that what I would
tell you is
um fantastic stocking stuffers fantastic
yeah
some stuff that you can hold on are you
guys selling pillows is that what you
just said yeah what if we did Listen
Hold on I do a little bit of marketing
here on the side let's go what if we did
King David body pillows
King David what body pillow like a
pregnancy pillow
so I can lay down in somebody's bed no
they will yeah
King David like this
on Daddy
on one side
let's do this
did you drink when you went to the
bathroom
hey Alex Alex tell me that that pillow
gonna have an arch to it
yeah then we have a p155 3D two dollar
Super Chat I guess in parentheses
parentheses in a pissed voice it's great
to see Alex here in the realm
really begrudging
shout out to you shout out to you then
we got Talia casares three dollars in
the chat yeah but it can't make a
multiplayer
if they wanted to change engines for
Halo they should look at the Cod engine
derivative of edtech because there are
already a lot of Studios there's already
a lot of support Studios available for
that engine
is not talking about a multiplayer
aspect of the game he's talking about
Halo that's what you're talking about
right Alex just Halo right see I mean
three four three can make a multiplayer
game it took him two games to do it yeah
listen I I get you don't worry about it
it's a bird party
we got post up five dollars Super Chat I
was about to say SOB Chief was just
twerking with Megan the stack and we uh
yeah twitch card it was lit no oh Jesus
then we got 108 dragons flame first hold
on I'll get back to it we got flame
first flame too loud Super Chat the
Volari the official IOP tutu yeah
first of all you better buy that tutu
yeah I don't see you in that tutu I'm
gonna see you don't be worrying about
what's going on underneath the pillow
you just focus on the pillows
[Laughter]
you know what I'm saying so um yeah
Activision Blizzard y'all this is my
topic so um shout out to
gamesindustry.biz
um Microsoft Activision Activision
Blizzard approved by Brazilian
Regulators so it looks like they were
the latest to approve the deal on the
administration of a council of economic
defense AKA Kade and that was yesterday
that they agreed to the merger with no
restrictions considering the huge
popularity of Call of Duty is reasonable
to infer that if Activision Blizzard
games were no longer available on Sony
consoles place to issue users could
decide to migrate to Xbox or even a PC
to continue having access to franchise
games okay you sent in a document and it
was kind of it was a bunch of poison
large document but I want to focus on
two specific points that four five four
and five yeah
fourth probably kind of broke the
internet in regards to previous
statements so they said with regards to
the possibility of closing Downstream
markets the analysis pointed out that
despite their evidence of popularity
Activision Blizzard games and in
particular the Call of Duty series would
not be essential assets to the
performance of Microsoft's current and
potential competitors in the console and
digital game distribution markets
in the latter both digital stores and
multiple game subscription services for
PC and consoles thus even if the
Activision Blizzard catalog would be
were to become exclusive to the
Microsoft ecosystem after the
transaction Kate considers that such
exclusivity would not result in the
substance reduction in the level of
competition in the downstream markets
even if Case got to stop laughing even
if it could translate into a competitive
Advantage for Microsoft and then step
five was kind of a little bit more even
more pointed it said furthermore if it
is highlight it is important to
highlight the central objective of
Cade's activities is the protection of
competition as a means of promoting the
well-being of Brazilian consumers and
not the defense of the particular
interests of specific competitors excuse
me excuse me my headset went out
you want me to run that back then
because you said they're not looking for
out for personal interest for oh they
were looking for the citizens the
central objective of Kane's activities
is the protection of competition as a
means of promoting the well-being of
Brazilian consumers and not the defense
of the particular interests of specific
competitors
part of that a part of uses a
PlayStation consoles from Sony could
decide to migrate to Xbox in the event
that Activision Blizzard games and
especially Call of Duty become exclusive
to the Microsoft ecosystem K does not
believe that such a possibility
represents in itself a risk to the
competition in the console Market as a
whole this has gone pretty viral Lord
Alex I know you had a video up on this
subject it was a lot of good videos a
lot of salt in the video so now that
this is settled a little bit what are
your thoughts of the Cades in the
Brazilian Authority Regulators analysis
of this and agreeing to the deal
it it honestly does make sense right
like you can't sit there and say
that just because Xbox has one big IP by
well I wouldn't say that because they're
going to have one of the biggest IPS in
the world by buying Activision Blizzard
that all of a sudden play Asian is no
longer going to exist that that's that's
that's a very
it's a very bad point to try to make
although Call of Duty is very large the
fact that they're going to have IPS that
they can go back and work on or whatever
is also great because Microsoft has
needed in fact to make games they're not
doing the right thing up until recently
so
it makes sense right if you have Disney
being able to buy a fox and buy all
those other companies to then go ahead
and provide that service for them we can
use that analogy if you want to
and you're looking at in terms of like
oh this is a monopoly has anyone looked
at embracer yep at all
I mean we're talking about one large
publisher absolutely
um but the thing is we're also looking
at embracer who was literally just
gobbling up every development Studio you
could possibly find whether they're BT
or not doesn't matter
that's actual development studios are
only going to be able to work on that
end and if you're looking at in terms of
like oh well they're going to take away
our exclusions or they take away Call of
Duty make it exclusive for the last 10
12 years all we ever heard was if you
want the exclusives just buy the Box
well buy the Box are you implying that
people should practice what they preach
that's fine I don't know you know like
and the funniest thing like I see people
like oh I'm not going to buy an Xbox
I'll spend three thousand dollars on the
PC like to what to have it sit and
collect dust in a closet because you're
never gonna use it are you implying that
these reactions are based on the
emotionality of of certain Gamers of
course I mean absolutely I mean the
thing is like what you're looking at
here is it's it's Corporate America baby
capitalism at its finest tell them about
it Alex tell them right tell them
little Bank always
but even then like you're looking at it
from that perspective I think
PlayStation has a phenomenal catalog of
developers that can easily make
competitive first-person shooters they
don't think so not to for some reason
Jim Ryan himself said he don't think so
yeah they said what was the words he
said we don't have anybody on our staff
that could do what they they do so we
just
you mean the like Insomniac who has
literally carried the PS5 for the last
two years true
let's be real they're the old insomnia
you think insomnia can make a Call of
Duty not even just make Insomniac you've
got bungee on your side
they just brought through the week
anything
here's a side project
remember when I said bungee was for the
seats for the streets right they just
brought them and then two weeks later
they said we have nobody on our staff
that can make anything like that so they
have no confidence in the people they
just got it's like what like why are you
doing any of this so I honestly hope
this goes through because I what I
really want to have happen is Microsoft
literally has a fire under them right
in some way whether or not that fire is
going to pay off with good games and
provide you with a unique value
proposition to buy their console use
their service is what's going to have to
be waited on yes
if this goes through Sony will have to
do something in order to push themselves
into a space that they have left and no
longer want to make games for they
cannot rely on Third Person cover based
action games with stealth elements they
can't do that anymore so maybe this will
light a fire under them to start making
even other games of different genres or
better games and so now you're going to
have two actual competing Giants who've
been competing for a long time provide
you with the content that you want
so why would you not want this to be to
go through and then for me all I care
about is maybe Mikey Barra and Phil will
fix blizzard
I mean that's how I'm looking at it
you're implying that so let me you're
implying that this is better than what
the the other result could be as opposed
to Activision staying in its current
course it pretending to the games that
you love specifically the blizzard games
wow you know things like that
yeah like for me it's blizzard has just
been completely down the hill and it's
just been something I've just been so
frustrated with and the fact that Mikey
bar is there and then the fact that
Phil's there hopefully Phil will go
ahead and start clearing that place out
so that way we can get blizzard games
back to where they were because Mikey
Barra does play his own game oh no he's
a game I play with my boy Michael boy
and everything I think Phil plays Diablo
or wow too yeah as well and so I'm like
like okay so what if we just actually
got blizzard back
like I think that's the big one you've
got oh shoot if you were just to tie the
wow sub to Game Pass
yeah that'll be huge yeah
that would be huge yeah yeah you throw
that the blizzard and the mobile app
there's a lot of potentially and I
definitely see you no And so there's so
much lizard IPS Yeah question question
so with that same thought process you
just said right there you go wow and all
Activision games and the blizzard games
and IPS old IPS
you still think Sony is out here having
a good fight oh Lord what do you mean
what is that what do you mean by that I
mean because you said it's going to be
healthy competition or it's going to be
and we are going to benefit from it as
The Gamers right right
I just just a question basically what he
is
I'm going paraphrase what they trying to
tell you basically Alex he tried to say
as a result of this do you envision Sony
still truly being able to compete
because according to you know King maybe
long term that you know these
accumulations will get solely out of the
console business I believe that was your
your words I said there's no PlayStation
stuff yes let's let's see stand on what
you said there's no PlayStation six no I
don't I think these consoles last 10
years to be honest with you and I think
that it was pushed behind you know for
the three years for the pandemic so I
thought it was gonna be eight years I
say 10 years at Max I hear Echo
um
10 years at Max right so
in that period of time I'm going by
Moore's Law and how technology will go
these guys are going towards services
and digital content I think at some
point in time they're just going to be
apps right and uh full goal all that
other stuff get them get controllers to
your TVs like they sell televisions they
have the app inside the television Sony
tried that before Microsoft is doing
that stuff now uh with LG and uh Samsung
get it inside your phones get it to
wherever you can get uh your digital
content from and play there I think
gaming is going to move into a totally
different space and to be honest with
you I don't think Activision or blizzard
is the target I think King is the target
myself sir
um I think King is the Target in that
whole thing because of the mobile aspect
of it because mobile is global and what
Microsoft heads want and what Phil was
alluding to that 8 billion people
don't all have consoles so those people
that he want to reach is the people that
have cell phones right so if you're
looking at it from that aspect if you
put that game pass inside everybody's
cell phone like a Netflix app when you
open up your apps and it's uh like a
stock app in your phone at some point in
time they're going to walk through it
they're going to see what it is if you
get the three months free so if you want
to reach those people and you have King
which are Kings in that mobile space
have those games Candy Crush those games
those games inside your phone so I think
King is more of the target to be honest
with you and I think both of them are
going to be getting out of the console
business and be going into digital and
store stuff like that what's your
thoughts on this sir I don't I don't see
that happening for quite a while mostly
because the infrastructure in the United
States is not prepared for that kind of
mobile gaming 10 years from now there's
no
okay now I think I think the issue is is
that even with the Advent of 5G we still
do not have the right capabilities for
5G to be effective and actually provide
you with the down bet with the bandwidth
that you need to actually play those
games without latency right I also think
too at the same time
as we get older and as other people
start coming up in the actual space the
and games become more competitive even
though they're service based latency is
still a factor yeah so now what happens
is do you design your games for that
latency right or do you say you know we
can't have that latency so we need to
have a box and I think too
us as individuals yes are we going to be
moving to a space where we stream
everything everything is on our phone
absolutely or it's both in the TV yes
100 I agree with you there whether or
not it will be next gen I do not think
so right because like Moore's Law
even though things get more effective
they also get cheaper yeah
so just because Moore's Law is effective
on that end does not mean that they
cannot make a console where they can
make a profit off of to provide that
console for people that want to play it
so yeah we may be the people that are
like the audio files that want a record
player right but that doesn't mean they
can't make money off those people
they're trying to make money as much
money as they can off everybody right
the ideal situation would be let me sell
you a 500 box but also you can play it
on the go on your phone but also you can
play it on your TV at the hotel
that's the ideal situation yeah and I I
definitely that's I think that's where
they would go yeah I think that's where
my alignment is because my thing is I
think we're still in that generational
transitionary period and I'm in
agreement with the competitive space I
think that everything else from a
streaming standpoint from A Game's
turn-based most action games it's fine
you know I'm simplify you got the
infrastructure you find but I just think
like super competitive like you talk
about the college strikes that you know
that's the Halos the cards and all that
where the latency is extremely key we're
not there yet you know what I'm saying
and again that's infrastructure as
you're still building out right they
still haven't gotten it out of which
into Sony's thing
um I just think that right now they're
still in transitioning model with their
whole business model as far as you know
retail and then streaming to me they're
just starting to Pivot but it'll be
interesting to see because if the king
is right on this I'm never gonna hit the
end of it but the thing about it is this
right he'll be right at some point at
some point yeah at some points I'm going
but I don't think I don't think we're
not gonna have a ps6 or
my my thought process with it is
um
not too long ago
I had on life
right and on life
like my uh
my compatriot here
knows the problem was latency and the
issues with bandwidth and stuff like
that right so we jumped in early
we didn't imagine stadia yeah right so
seeing stadia and I think that's
probably like 10 years to the date
probably close yeah yeah 10 years to
today
um it's in the browser
the tech was good and uh Assassin's
Creed Odyssey
absolutely nuts to be running there the
the games that we were running before on
on live was you know ac2 yeah went to
sell stuff like that
um
I just see it in a different uh thought
process as far as how technology is
going to go and I understand exactly
what you're talking about from a
Commerce standpoint yeah for these
people in this part of the world maybe
have a Roku stick or something like that
I have absolutely no idea but um and
like you said cheaper yeah get it to
them for like 200 or 100 with a control
or something
um they're going to be working downward
instead of upward to be honestly because
how little man is selling
it's showing you that
super high powered yes for Niche right I
gotta have it I I gotta have a series X
plus I got like six series S's
I didn't get six series X so at some
point in time back me I'm gonna be the
dinosaur they're not gonna look at me no
more they're gonna look at the masses
and they're going to start catering to
the masses no I get where you go we
could feel you a little early
yeah it's the same concept I'm Gonna
Keep You market like a a an actual PC
Gamer is not going to look at the 80 or
90 series cards they're gonna look at
the 60 series yes if you're in a video
fan you know I feel like
in order for that to happen
someone had to make an Xbox one mistake
like someone's gonna a company's gonna
have to like a massive company a gaming
company he's gonna have to jump in it
face first and completely drop the ball
and then someone else is gonna pick it
up and and evolve it yeah
it's something that can't happen
overnight but like for instance like the
digital the digital age like you know if
you would ask me at the beginning of the
360 generation yo is this all digital
thing gonna work out it says you
probably not but now we get to the point
where
a lot of games are selling more
digitally than they're actually selling
physically so like it's just but and
that's even
that was a a less of a hill to climb
than Cloud streaming entirely because a
lot more people they might have not
access to you know internet to download
stuff is different than not having
access to Internet to play games yeah so
you know it's I do think it is going to
happen like King said but I think you
know I don't think it's ever going to
replace the box I think it's always
gonna it would have to get to the point
where more people are playing the cloud
versions of these games than the actual
games for these companies to look and be
like this is a valuable thing that we
can actually just ditch the consoles
because all these platforms would love
to ditch the consoles but it's necessary
to actually do that business with the
consoles because I don't think we're at
the point where there's too many people
that are openly okay with playing it on
platforms and I don't think that's going
to change anytime in the infrastructure
what I wanted to stay on point with you
um addict in reference to the actual the
Brazil thing I want to get back on point
with that so like now that they have
come out and they have pretty much
okayed the deal like what what's your
feeling on that you know just that them
agreeing to it and then moving forward
I agree with them I think that you know
some of these companies have their hand
in the cookie jar too much you know
they're talking about Sony this Sony
that like look Sony could still could
easily compete without Call of Duty it's
just they're not going to make as much
money as they normally would with Call
of Duty like and that's the part that
just like blows my mind it's like look
like I do agree that Call of Duty is a
big massive brand but Sony's a massive
brand
PlayStation is a massive brand and it's
like I said last week like how is the
number one going to tell the number four
this ain't Fair
we we need to put handcuffs on number
four
because I feel like they I feel like
they do it
are you implying is their personal
interest on taking precedence over the
the the what's right for gamers yeah
it's it's like equivalent to you know
I'm out of shape I'm gonna go get I'm
gonna get in shape man sitting there
getting in shape and subdued at the gym
been there for years doing way better
than me he's like I don't like this this
dude built better than me
all the protein shakes
he calling all his sponsorship friends I
like this dude this dude looked at me
funny in the gym talking to the gym
memory talking to Jim owner this dude
spit on me what I was trying to do a
[ __ ] his access to all the muscle milk
is is gonna be could not be a
competitive playing field for me it's
just like you know Brazil showed when
they said it was like look like and I
didn't even really think about it too
much but after I read that I was like
yeah they're right like these people are
spending too much time thinking about
how is this going to affect Sony and not
does this affect the consumers that buy
games
yeah and I think that's also a big
factor as well like you've got all this
stuff here and and trying to sit here
and care about a multi-billion dollar
corporation that doesn't even know you
exist I think it's just
fools
oh What's it gonna do for selling you
it's not my it's not your concern you're
you'll sit on the board
like what do you care yeah it's it's
very like that's not your problem it's
very interesting right now Lord stop
your thoughts Brazil had a lot to say
what are your thoughts on that
it's the first Domino to fall and then
and more to come and I what I like is
that they they point out
specifically the problem with Sony's
argument here and this is why from the
beginning I've always said this is a
stupid point to argue because if you
it's being very short-sighted on
Playstation side that they chose to
argue the Call of Duty point because at
the end of the day if you really want to
stop Microsoft you really want to stop
them ABK is not a big deal in the long
term King mentioned King right that part
of ABK which is gonna get Microsoft in
so many different places right that's
huge but at the end of the day
they needed to argue
the entire infrastructure that Microsoft
is building with Azure
right right and maybe that's it but at
the end of the day if you really want to
stop them dead in their tracks that's
the argument you needed to make that hey
all of this stuff that they're building
we don't have a prayer in Hell of doing
anything even close to that they're
going to be in so many places that
doesn't matter what they have and what
they're selling they're gonna sell to
somebody
and we can't do that we can't get there
in the same way right it was always a
very stupid and short-sorted I it felt
like Jim Ryan was trying to get one over
on Regulators that don't know anything
about gaming
off the platform and the funny thing is
I like the way they call them all like
nah that's not a big deal like nah like
I'm not worried about you like when I
felt like the person in charge of Brazil
like actually games it's like oh that's
all yeah oh yeah
oh is that is that what we're talking
about
Fan Fest in Brazil
yeah there was a lot of like stuff going
around that like Oprah's it was an Xbox
country
Microsoft paid to pay they paid to to
improve something in Sao Paulo or
something like that like everybody
every company does that every company
so it was it was always something that
was going to backfire when I saw it it
was funny it was petty I had to give Jim
his flowers just because it it felt like
this super uh not aggressive right he
was in is very passive in putting
themselves in a weak position to see if
they somebody would would have would
take Mercy on them would be like okay
well I feel spend it though I feel sorry
oh [ __ ] and it backfired because it was
never the argument you should have made
when you look at everything that else
that they're doing
this is a Colossus that you can't stop
you can't take down this Colossus right
and you should have attacked that if you
really wanted attack you should have
been like hey
Azure is going to be everywhere within
the five within five years with anger
comes game pass with Azure comes the
expansion they're going to keep buying
more things because at the end of the
day as much money as Microsoft has they
want to be able to own the vast majority
of stuff that goes in the game pass you
don't want you don't want to be paying
licensing fees for all of this stuff or
whatever end of the day it was always
going to be the case that they're going
to continue to buy stuff in order to
have it in-house so they control that
entire pipeline right stem discern they
own everything
that was the argument to make because
there's no way in hell Sony can go there
right and then on top of that you make
this argument
when the number two guys that are closer
to them I'm like I don't care like it
doesn't bother me so you're gonna
LeapFrog you're LeapFrog and Nintendo
and you're being like Oh but it's gonna
harm me but it's not gonna harm Nintendo
didn't care didn't Sony and intensin
just have some kind of like business
Arrangement too like recently there's
like a there's some ownership and they
both own a pieces of from yeah from
something like that so the crazy thing
is like you can make business
arrangements for people that's closer on
your on yourself than than Microsoft but
when Microsoft makes any type of
Acquisitions it's an issue like it's
just like I said like the biggest issue
with this is Microsoft is going in areas
that they can't follow they can't put
that kind of they can't and they're
probably they're low-key probably trying
to they're probably tired of getting
outbid by selling it by Microsoft too
now let's get them up out of here I mean
I always make them they're taking them
into deep Waters where they can't follow
and they they try to follow they're
going to drown them and
and to me you know you
hopefully they realize this right
hopefully they realize this and when
they Microsoft moves to acquire the next
thing they'll argue better so because
but because our again the Cod thing Cod
is a big fish in a relatively small
place
[Laughter]
that's what I honestly feel this this is
more about Sony not being able to
capitalize on that that you know that 30
they get every year from from God this
has nothing to do with can they compete
with that I agree I think it's all the
same point I think we kind of know they
know this so what what really is it
right what what really is going on
because they they they I I find it hard
to believe that they are not intelligent
enough to understand that part right so
to me this got to be so is it just
stalling like we've talked about before
just stalling or concessions right and
okay what can we Brazil said no
restrictions
finish up did I get kicked
man to me honestly it just the argument
never made any sense this was always
going to happen the rest of the The
Dominoes will fall I think hargit should
he mention something in a Super Chat
Berkeley that I I also feel the same
like maybe you get a little more
pushback in in areas where Sony is a lot
more dominant Europe right you maybe get
a little bit maybe the wording is a
little bit different at the end of the
day it all still goes through I think
um and that's it like again not not a
not a smart argument again the
concessions thing makes sense to me I
get it because at the end of the day
what they really do want is for COD to
stay on their platform right whatever
the cost it is right but
you know Phil holds the cards there like
honestly hey whatever the cost exactly
that you really didn't expect where he
was like okay I'll give it to you for
three more years yeah yeah that was big
but what other what other CEO does that
yeah exactly like you're my main
competition yeah you can have for three
more years he said uh give it to you for
three more years and then pass
for sure right
all of those arguments going down like
yeah so you can have it but caveat this
but it just feels like sold in game
passes and another thing is and again
and it's and it feels like it's Jim
again trying to posture and make himself
look out to be the victim in the public
forum because when you really look at it
smart business tells you don't get into
call don't get into bed with Cod for 10
years you don't know what God's Gonna
become you never know right who's gonna
make a deal in perpetuity yeah just you
never know every three years reassess it
because if Microsoft is making money
with you guaranteed they'll be willing
to go to the table whatever the cost may
be to to continue that right it causes
Spiderman
see him in his webs and his web shooter
they would like let's say that there is
a deal like that that was thrown at them
do you think Sony would like relinquish
the the exclusivity rights on like
Spider-Man or maybe the Final Fantasy
brand to keep caught on there I think to
be honest with you yeah we put in the
sky but I I can you know looking at
looking at how
um Jim Ryan does business
it would be it it would surprise me if
that conversation has not come up
because he's like Spider-Man Spider-Man
said we could make so much money with
Spider-Man under the table
Red Rover
Revenue it's about is it revenues
Brazil
in not having an issue with the uh
activation blizzard can't do
so the guys at the gate again who party
Kawaii Joe
[Laughter]
what do you want we get you gave us
everything already what do you want well
well they they they're they're also
making these
shut up
Jim
you're in the lead spot you're number
one why are you worrying about number
five number four on a good day
Jim handle your business this is very
Godfather you're making us look bad in
these streets
you're writing
you went to Brazil Jim
Brazil flew out there for business you
don't even speak Spanish
hey hey call it King when he said you
went to Brazil gym chips like but it was
on my vacation
and Brazil just getting to PS3 now
so you know listen Brazilians is very
heavy on that non-stitching stuff
not about that right there that protect
their own
so when you got back the paperwork and
they said yo we passed that what they
didn't get the PlayStation fives I sent
no the checking Claire why didn't you
sit in the chair they got them they put
them in the stadium that Microsoft built
um listen here Jim
big Bank East little bank right
no restrictions not right there when you
heard no restrictions you know they all
in inside Sony headquarters are like
what what what Brazil said no today
let's be real king they're like Jim what
did you say what did you say what was on
that paper Jim that you said what was on
that paper Jim a kid at this man he said
Jim Don't You Buck up on me don't you
Buck up on me Jim this this is gonna
come this is gonna cost us a ton of
money Jim
oh we bring a buck back I'm gonna tell
you Jim here we go
at this moment Jim
what is this they said no restrictions
clearly
[Laughter]
it's a gym
now I'm gonna tell you
the moment you caused this Call of Duty
you know over there you started
snitching and ratting and putting people
out
they're good people Jim
what we work with them Jim we got
business practices with them gym for
God's sakes what the hell is wrong with
you
Jim Jim Don't You Buck up on me
kid what the [ __ ] up you can't be
I want you to do I want you to go right
there
and I want you to write an apology
to the Brazilian regulator and I want
you I want you I want you
I want you to write an apology for
everybody is snitched on
and all the people you snitched too oh
he snitched on Phil well he did and you
know what you want no you know what Phil
needs
now I want you to wrap up Spider-Man
oh Lord and I want you to hand deliver
that to him
to make it right and beg for his
forgiveness oh Lord and holy can you do
for that can you do that for me didn't
Xbox Skip and pass on Spider-Man uh
listen they wanted them to make it so
they can take it later
[Laughter]
no I'm sure I'm sharp I'm sharp they
said now you gonna build a better boat
we're gonna take that boat
so I'm gonna tell you man
for all you kids watching
and for all you kids trying to figure
out life
stop snitching
so this is Adrian you look like now is a
fool that snitched
don't snitch the end result is don't
snitch because what did he get him
he got him no restrictions
you know why it put a spotlight on his
head
and they said you're number one why the
hell are you worrying about number four
and they looked at the books they said
Jim no matter what they do with that
thing right there they're not gonna mess
with you what is
give them no restriction let them do
whatever the hell they want to do I hope
they still Call of Duty away from them
so I don't got to see this guy
she's downstairs again in the coffee
room
you can't snitch on that guy twice
[Laughter]
well all right yeah we got the analysis
foreign
[Laughter]
stuff that I see there the other thing
that I thought was interesting though
that we didn't mention was that Xbox
launched the website Pride it is about
the abkd which is hilarious to me
because I'm kind of desperate yeah I'm
like who is this for but but you know
what's funny Alex the reason why there's
a part of me that feels it was a
defensive move just in case Jim
prior statements with the inadequacy I
remember Jim was actually saying Gerard
was actually saying hey we're happy the
EU was looking into this and the further
investigation so to me it felt like
maybe Microsoft said to himself let's
not be overconfident let's down our eyes
Let's cross our T's and I don't know who
this is particularly for this is for
regulated is this for the I don't know
who this statement is for about
understanding the benefits of the
activism it is kind of yeah like like
that was like so that was so awesome it
was very weird but it it showed to me
the seriousness of this deal going
through for bikers so if they're willing
to put up some site like this I thought
it was interesting but moving forward
let's get back to Brazil look they they
they they fundamentally answered all the
questions they shut down everything they
even reference Sony's own subscription
model themselves as far as PlayStation
Plus how that affects as far as
orchestra that they have and to me the
other key that they said that I've
always been saying is if you're going to
say that this this is this Call of Duty
is this astronomical force that this
undeniable thing in gaming that there's
no way you can compete with it on scale
and by Microsoft having this
Brazil literally said tell us how
Nintendo is existing without Call of
Duty and I thought it was kind of
brilliant now to to Alex's point I'm in
agreement this is just Brazil and their
Regulators we have to see with the EU
and I will say this to defend Jim
and I know I don't see nobody saying
this and I know people at some of you
made a good point people are like yo why
is he doing this why is he it's a bad
faith argument right and why and like
why would they put themselves in the
public Bullseye like this because most
people feel they don't have a strong
argument my Counterpoint to it is that
one let's be real Jim Ryan established
himself his Reign is through the EU
right Sony
to Japan was Sony Japan he shifted Sony
Japan and so to Saudi EU and made them
dominant in the region again I have no
inside information but I am going to
assume during this Reign you can't tell
me that Jim Ryan doesn't have strong
Connections in the space of the EU right
so my thing is if you're willing to fly
on planes the Brussels or do all these
things you're willing to do you're going
to try to utilize your first of all his
his job is to his stakeholders period
that's right so I'm not even mad at the
hustle as far as saying that the deal is
bad this is bad for gamers or whatever
he's saying I'm not mad you gotta you
gotta protect your company I get that my
thing is
the fact that Microsoft made a website
encountered to that I thought it was
interesting yeah and the facts yes I
feel that again I have to wish that they
know that in case he has any influence
in the region to if there is any chance
he could influence it whether it be shot
the whole law in the emergency
acquisition lawyers like right now he
feels like 70 30. if that 30 is even a
thing then we have to make sure we get
out to the public here's the verbiage we
want and then the thing that I think is
respected I respect it and the thing
that I think is very interesting now
which is going to give Microsoft
tremendous Leverage is even though it's
a different region they can use the
exact verbiage the Brazilian Regulators
use and say you see this is why we feel
we we you know we're still not competing
I can see them going in there and saying
you know what did Brazil say no
restrictions
I think the I think the reason they did
that is they're like look like we're
pretty confident we have this but
let's not get cocky right and there's
just like let's not automatically assume
that we got the golden ticket the golden
ticket might be fake because you date
listed this deal from a Microsoft
perspective cannot afford the fair if
this was to get blocked from someone's
getting fired like this is very very
confident yeah yeah of course
but someone who's smart is you don't be
overconfident and you don't over uh you
don't underestimate what your
competition could potentially don't
follow me down that River yeah the last
point I'll say is
softly is I do think Phil I mean Jim
knows this
is
okay
this is about consensus
what did I do to this podcast
this is about concessions this is about
how much like eight years we could get
out of this deal from Call of Duty you
know that Microsoft themselves is like
look we we are willing to capitulate
that if it means being on Playstation
forever I mean whatever they're willing
to do it yeah but they unless The
Regulators tell them
I'm gonna tell you this and I think like
like you said
a lot of things are said contracts is
different oh no I know where you go I
know
I mean I'm just saying I offered I
offered that offers
a few minutes I was talking to you
there's a lot of things that was done
okay
and if it's me
and me you cool and I go out of my way
for you a lot of things for you and then
soon as I turn my back like a rat you
stab me in the spine I'm telling you Jim
I cannot wait and it's gonna be so much
fun and I and listen get it I got all of
them I got all the consoles I get it so
if Call of Duty is not here I get it and
I listen I want to play Spider-Man right
what I do shut off my Xbox turn on my
PlayStation right
it's going to happen the same way buddy
look the fact to your credit the fact
that Brazilian Regulators even mentioned
a scenario where the exclusivity deal
ends and they still feel that it was not
going to give them a competitive
advantage and they even mentioned people
would get placed PlayStation fans would
get Xbox consoles they don't look at
that as a competitive shift that is
Major and Microsoft is going to utilize
a lot of these same arguments in these
next regulatory meetings oh I got to
tell Alex just go I you really need to
know where my Sony hate lies oh Lord all
right you really need to know because I
know it sounds like a lot of vitriol
yeah
right they killed my Sega and let me
tell you something oh God we don't
forget the old country
yeah no more Super chats I have to solve
leaf
y'all ready
okay cool we got oh okay so correction
my apologies it's uh pissed five dollar
Super Chat not a pissed voice oh yeah
p155 3DS actually the thing is when I
copy paste them it's harder to see it
but if I look at it in the actual chat
of the show I can tell that it's it's
just he's the same people I gotta break
pop protocol shout out to the legendary
hip-hop game in the building he said yo
yo my brother for life let's go to
islands in the building laugh out loud
Sony kill Sega kick it's hilarious
salute the hip-hop it's wild yeah
so my apologies is it was actually
pissed
uh I love Alex been catching his salt
videos for about six months now so yeah
he wasn't salty about Alex Vietnam oh
okay absolutely that's good that's good
then we got Stitch remember for two
years two dollars to attack give play oh
my god get play with my joystick a soft
body pillow chat
great show I got a dip out for a family
Barbecue represent with my throne in the
bushes hoodie Brazil made the correct
decision suck it Jim Russia it's so
fantastic that you got to throw them in
the bushes hoodie because those are
collectible items and soon they'll be
moving from the store because attic has
something yeah
we have somebody woke a sleeping
unicorny two pound Super Chat breaking
news PlayStation are re-bleaching pong
on the PlayStation
you can expect similar call outs from
most of the Regulatory Agencies given
the ridiculous market share PlayStation
has in those territories like we said
FTC is the only Wild Card could go fine
could have some agenda
then we have clutch man five dollar
Super Chat just woke up to see that oh
no it's Alex has been acquired by the
Lord
oh man what timeline did I fall into
this will be a fire show hit the like
button yes yes Alex gonna build it yeah
you know then we have Sebastian h two
dollar Super Chat Sony without staff
said staff is uh Doom remakes
yeah y'all be talking about that
certainly then we have post up ten
dollars we chat the ABK acquisition was
never about Cod it has always been about
putting Microsoft in a position to try
and disrupt the
disrupt the distribution model on mobile
the next battle is app store policy side
loading Etc
that should be interesting yeah I
alluded to that earlier then we have
heartbeat she needs 10 super chat with
ABK Xbox checks off three three B Gamers
uh King gets them King gets them there
as for cloud keep in mind hybrid Cloud
will exist local elements that run on
your device TV phone Etc background runs
in the cloud yeah
yeah then we have NC ghost of low road
of low road 200 chat my question would
be is PlayStation a brand like Nintendo
to determine if if you see anything past
the ps6 because the moves they make seem
to insinuate that they believe that they
will sell off the name alone right that
was part one okay
so part two is ten dollar Super Chat
Spider-Man being the exception is
cradles or Last of Us also a brand that
could match the same popularity or
enough people buying playing their games
or Cod
I mean yeah that's a long question did
you wait did you just say Spider-Man or
God of War oh tell them to drop on Call
of Duty day yeah and you'll find out
exactly who got the biggest cojones in
the room and who don't play drop on that
thing all right I'm exclusive don't run
with the big dogs I done told you y'all
poodles and watch the big dog come over
here and we shut them off from yo yo yo
Fountain is over and yes Alex I do have
my Xbox
very toxic you're very very tired
Alex
that's about to cook you clean bro
have fun have fun listen make sure I'm
well done
moving on oh
all right
[Laughter]
I don't care how much dance moves out in
these streets snitching me as a consumer
need to see Call of Duty on Game Pass
day and date yes it'll be there I see
all the bucket up I'm done moving on
then we have Sebastian eight to two
dollars Super Chat Alex and the bald men
podcast yes
that we have Oh Donna we got a couple
more like man it's a chat
[Music]
yeah we got flame two dollar Super Chat
Brazil really went stop teasing him Jim
yeah
salute the flame that's what's up then
you have Lord Metro to our Super Chat so
I'll use Alberto v05 after saving no me
and thanks
wow then we have uh NC ghost of low road
again two dollars in the chat they
killed my Dreamcast with the DVD player
too that's right I say listen let the
blood flow
messy continue yeah we got one away
dragons five dollar Super Chat let's not
forget the governing bodies are there to
protect the consumer not the company's
interest peeps need to learn this and
stop using the Monopoly argument yes it
was always send that letter over the gym
always a stupid argument yeah then we
have hard to knee 20 laws the King's
Point when PlayStation came into the
market we had trouble Graphics 16 3DO
Neo Geo Atari Jaguar Amiga Nintendo and
of course Sega Sony comes in money has
everything and all of them died Nintendo
had to reinvent itself to come back what
that that is you see people forget about
history right that is very true and I
loved every last one only and and I
remember remember and we we've known
this and we talked about it and ACG
alluded to it when he was on Sony
specifically bought certain developers
to shut them down during the PS1
generation in order for Sega not to get
them so yeah I mean there's a lot of
dirt I feel like now it's a lot more
companies are more acceptable on making
time exclusives and stuff and then yeah
back then probably yeah just to make an
arrangement for particular games
it's always been a dirty business young
Odin
go go buy Sony and close them moving on
because
we are caught up and I am all right
brother later brother have a blessed day
I hope everything works out well yeah
definitely everything should be okay I
appreciate it Alex pleasure my brother
no doubt we'll keep this pushing this
last two up really quick yeah so I mean
this is King this is your topic on
Playstation man in the news again Herman
host in the PlayStation Studios head and
he's been making the media rounds a lot
of topics but what in particular for
King that is his topic I'll set up for
him so yeah it looks like he was uh
making the rounds and one of the key
statements that he said is that there
will be at least a year between
PlayStation console and PC game releases
with exception to live service games
those will be day in day with PC and
console and this has definitely been
making the rounds as well as the salt
rounds for Lord Alex's channel so let's
get right into it um don't ask man what
do you feel about this because this has
been a point of contention for a lot of
certain uh groups of people as far as
the the time window and that there would
never be any day-to-date games to PC
so what do you feel being that you know
obviously PC is a platform that you you
like the game
um I think it's I think it's bound to
happen the day and day will have at some
point even with their the exclusive
argument that they have there
um I think what they're doing is they're
just putting it for a year like what a
minimum right yeah yeah I mean the thing
is
here's the argument that I see a lot
what's the reason for owning a
PlayStation
what I haven't played if I don't have
exclusives well basically you don't have
to game on PC you clearly don't like PC
gaming so you're on Console the value of
the console is not determined by whether
or not somebody else can play that game
that's the only value you see in a
console then why are you just then just
don't [ __ ] play games and just stick
with your own toys
right so this idea that oh there's only
value in something if no one else has it
unless they also buy it like I did I
think it's a really Antiquated and like
very dumb argument because there is no
argument so okay I have to spend the
same money you spent in order to play a
video game why
like when you think about it in that
perspective you're like oh that is
really stupid you know like who like who
cares bro
um and so
the second argument that I see is oh we
invest into consoles or into the
companies no you don't invest you
purchase a product yes
like that's all you do is the product
good did you buy it yes do you like it
that should be the end of where things
go so just because a game goes on on PC
doesn't mean that is that it's no longer
playable
is it going to sell or it stops working
or like or they go back and they charge
your account the 60 bucks back that you
paid for you know like that's a dumb
argument you know so I think I think
it's going to happen at some point where
it's going to be day and day on PC
because they just want to maximize the
return they can get for the games that
they develop and they try to make as
much money as possible so I mean XBox
guys had to deal with it
yeah and when y'all dealt with it I was
there
a lot of resistance there you know hey
hey you know it was never resisted it
actually yeah yeah David you took it all
real good yeah yeah listen listen listen
you'll be surprised oh y'all two
together now oh they're soft yeah
very nice I'm a big boy
continue to ask a question Alex please
you can take a lot yeah
I think I think oh
hey yo last time I heard you were a
switch
the right batter coming in the hot it is
going left
continue Alex oh you're uh
Let It Go day in day let it be a year
whatever like that's just a that's not a
what's what's the matter oh you get to
talk about the game too awesome what I
would like to see though is integration
for PSN to wear just like Xbox I can log
in yes and get trophies on PC but also
get steam achievements I think that
would be awesome I love that and you see
them but I mean playing around with
integration I'm sorry yeah but but I
mean like there are people who don't
want to game on PC that's fine they're
people who want to play on their on
their TV that's fine and that gaming and
the PC gaming has nothing to do with you
nothing it is for people like me who do
not want to spend 500 on a plastic box
when I can save that money to get a new
PC in fact right like that's really what
it's about no absolutely you're making a
fantastic point because at the end of
the day these corporations are here to
make money it's about profit and if this
gives them extra life on on titles that
they have and they're going to do it
they're going to utilize and like you
said eloquently it doesn't affect the
Quant console Gamers experience it's
actually long term enhances it because
at the end of the day that's more money
going into development and maybe
potential more iterations of that series
or franchise that you like so there's
also some potential devs right I hear
you but uh and of course that they would
do that like why else like you they're
just going to make the money and just
like just keep it I know right
yeah that's a good they're gonna make
more content with it and that's fine
whether it's a year later you know like
unless you're okay
yeah unless he needs a yacht which is
probably what he's gonna get but you
know like oh good they're investing it
like I saw one guy who was like oh good
they're putting it back in the ecosystem
for PlayStation what else would they do
with it
bonuses what else is there bonuses
bonuses and they all gonna buy Chiclets
yeah
dude like what you know like it's just
one so you saw that too like the
argument I saw was oh the quality uh
they won't be able to the Quality will
degrade because
I think that's true good what quality I
think so why oh I'm not gonna say this
yeah
I'm just going to say this where's the
question they released two games this
year so far what was that the Horizon
forbidden West and greatness yeah the
Gran Turismo right
them bugs
oh so the PC parts had something to do
with this um not not the PC people okay
I'm just talking about the fact that
they have to make stuff and put it up
I'm Alex I'm being full right now
oh so you you you're standing to see a
degradation basically I've but I've been
saying it though oh yeah I'm just saying
that I'm seeing the slip you've had the
slips I'm seeing them I see age creeping
in like kid I can't dismiss so Champion
got old knees continue Alex when people
say quality right you know what they
mean they mean graphics
that's what they mean now you got to say
like oh in the game when I when I touch
the snow there's the snow deform in the
way that I want it to deform right you
know like that's all that that's that's
what the quality people are talking
about Graphics can be done no matter
what that's stupid art style is superior
over graphics
you know and it's like oh but the
details that's not quality that's just
wasted time on [ __ ] it's like Red
Dead Redemption 2 that I need to see my
horse's balls
absolutely not
yes I have the old red dead and he
didn't have any anyway let's move it off
of y'all too did y'all but but that's
but that's that's the whole argument
right and so and they don't understand
it like that's why they bought Nexus
that's my heart
they get them over there officially
when you find out they baby
this was actually really bad
right now stop that
he loves them you know like Spider-Man
is 80 of my CPU usage on eight quarts
Alex
[Laughter]
now PC live service game day and date
single playing games one year Attica we
feeling
I think it's good for the PlayStation
brand you know uh I do agree that it
devalues the console but I don't think
that here's the thing
when you offer it somewhere else it does
devalue the original product but people
be acting like it's this large number no
it's not like for the most part uh the
PlayStation brand is going to gain more
off of event giving it access to the PC
market because there's a lot of people
like Alex uh do you have a PlayStation 5
out I can't remember because I know you
don't have a PS a PS3 yeah
PS4 and then I threw it into a lake oh
thanks
it was so the BET was so desk driving
was announced and I was like all right
so I was like all right well I gotta
play God of War I gotta play this right
I gotta play bloodborne for streams so I
might as well just get one yeah and so
this trending was announced and I was
like yo this ever comes on PC I throw my
I throw my PS4 and I'm like
and then like six months later it hits
QC
so and then and then in the middle so in
the middle of Press Start I was like you
saw y'all I gotta do it so I put my
fingers into the grooves of the PS4 and
I pulled apart the PS4 oh you took the
wing though
you know it's supposed to do that right
I can't yeah I know it's not
it's like gym pants
yeah you rip away gym pants that's what
I did and it just came off okay I stop
bonding so we can do this yeah
and then after that and then after that
I just I just chucked it into a lake and
I was like there it's gone so you know
they're gonna gain more at the
PlayStation brand itself the PlayStation
ecosystem there's plenty of people like
Alex that don't own a PS5 that would
play the games if it was on the PC so
there's way more of them than there are
people that won't buy that that won't
get anything because it's not on PC like
the funny thing is like shirt you offer
a lot of people and there's a lot of
people like you know uh yeah to a point
like BG you know he he definitely
happened even if everything was on PC
day one brand efficiently 100 fine he's
still buying a PlayStation 5. but
there's a lot of people just randomly
got smoked specifically but there there
is a lot of people that wouldn't buy
PlayStation 5 that own a PC and they
only own it for like two or three games
a year they probably wouldn't
but there's not a lot of them you know
for the most part you're going to get
more benefits out of games going to PC
than you would of having that you know
one out of every 10 person I wouldn't
buy a PlayStation if they knew the game
was coming to their platform so uh it's
just like I said like you know same
thing with the Xbox uh it did devalue
the the platform but it didn't devalue
the ecosystem I feel like it more money
is more money like there's no way you
devout yourself got some points for you
and Alex he said day one disrespect
console gamers in his opinion one year
is a good compromise and then um he also
said console Gamers get charged to play
online don't they what do you feel oh
yeah hold on that's fine
I don't agree with the disrespect's
opinion wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait you actually think these companies
respect you
oh they're gonna respect you no they
don't respect you they respect your
wallet and they don't care but he said
that the gate console Gamers get charged
to play a lot he said and that's fine
sorry like this Sunday
is I I I'm stream marking every time
Alex cusses so I can peep it out
[Music]
I mean that's there you have it there
you have it it's just like when it comes
down to it like look I don't agree with
that you know you should want what's
best for the platform you play on if you
can get if if your games can be a bigger
budget later on because they had more
access to money by going to the PC
market you can get a bigger game like
you know God of War who who's to say
that Ragnarok since they knew God of War
was coming out on PC and they knew that
fluctuate of money was coming they're
like okay let's give you a little bit of
bigger of a budget than we normally
would because we know we're going to get
a little bit of that money on the back
end when it comes to PC when the
original one comes to PC let's let's
give them a little bit more padding on
stuff what's like a little more
attention to detail let's do that and
it's just like to me I don't understand
why people are so against their platform
being in a better State like more money
is never a bad thing I'm with you I'll
jump it real quick I think what has
happened there and I got to give
PlayStation a little spoken because the
a little the only on Playstation you
know verbiage the they have built up a
culture right that this is the place to
play Playstation is the place to play
for the last generation and a lot of
their bottle is based on exclusivity
it's based on having content that you
can't get anywhere else so it is
emboldened the base a bit to say hey
this is this is the premium product this
is where you do this at right so the in
the defense of the base there is going
to be a slight pushback when they start
to hear even though this makes perfect
business sense even though from a
corporation standpoint I get it it but
they are partly responsible for this old
there this creation of this angry base a
little bit because they've embolded them
to say yo exclusive I remember having
those boxes are no longer there I get it
but a lot of the common guy won't know
that Twitter let's be honest is Echo
chamber right two dollars from all PS5
is Buggy Games remix God of War Captain
all right anyway so I remember getting
those boxes remember you get them blue
PS4 about only on places and then now it
says on PlayStation and everywhere else
[Laughter]
first off we got a little over 800.
you're definitely hit that like button
let's get over to 500 I'll bring up
something that you guys want me to bring
second off uh you know it's it's like
Ralph said in in the chat you know PS5
has been a more of a buggy system than
normal returnal was crashing the
PlayStation five like when they brought
him and shut them up put them in the
corner and said don't you ever say that
but don't you ever say that Horizon was
extremely buggy when it came out so it's
just like you know they're like oh well
you know we want we want these gains to
be more quality your the games right now
aren't quality like they are constantly
breaking down so what kind of that makes
no sense it's like look like you know
they they be acting like you know what's
funny Alex I was on a podcast once I
can't remember who it was and they were
arguing with me saying that PlayStation
can't make two ports at once and I'm
like there is plenty of AAA products
that make multiple and I was like what
are you so you're telling me that a
company is incompetent yeah that's what
I was saying I was like you have no
faith in your platform to be able to
develop on PC but they can't make it for
the PC
no you know what you know what's crazy
it's just like no I'm sorry these
consoles are x86 rpcs they're basically
form factor PCS and they're crazy what
are you talking about is you're looking
at from that standpoint and it's just
like okay then explain to me how
Rockstar makes four platforms most the
time like it's just like they made 360
like it's just it makes no sense and
that's the part that just frustrates me
because it's like instead of just saying
yo we're gonna get these games you know
they're coming a year later now they're
push in the go plus more well yours not
that bad you know we it's never but
again but back in the day Alex remember
it was three years three years ain't
that bad it's gonna be three four years
before you get these days now though
dude now you're you're you're you're
you're dude is sitting there he's
sitting on top of his little Podium and
he's like you waiting a year yeah in
defense I gotta you know me I've always
done we ain't defended no boys gotta be
Devil's Advocate I always gotta try to
understand why doesn't they get annoying
I can't wait till it's my turn gotta be
objective all I said is that they Saudi
has to hold the blame for emboldening
the base to feel that way right no no no
no no okay I'm about to stop you right
please go ahead so you mean to tell me
that simps fell for marketing oh
marketing wait wait wait what did you
call them it's Simpson I use the same
phrase before and somebody took a person
they've been involved in Alex they've
been involved by that let them get them
bowling they are less than half of a
percent of the actual base that buys
games
but you're speaking common sense I'm
speaking I'm speaking emotionality
which will get banned if I said let's be
real here too you got a lot of
especially influencers in this direct
Community they have built their whole
personality right inside themselves
some of them have done it so long right
that that's who they are they're not a
personality they're not a Persona
anymore that's who they are an addict
that's why there is the Betrayal feeling
from this this base how dare you do this
to me I championed you you know what
that's my identity yes you know what
good
that sounds like a you bro
I'm just saying that's why you see the
victory old that's why you see that
sounds like a you promise hey look I
hope there's more of it you put a chance
or I know you hope for the chance
no doubt oh you know what Alex you'll
make one crazy video when games go day
and day to PC you know they're gonna be
plenty of last week I'm gonna give it to
you but my last point is just that I
think I just gonna like that I think
this is a slow greasing to be honest
right it's also it's only it's a slow
greasy
you boil a frog how do you do it slowly
slowly yeah oh it's only gonna be it's
only going to be you know it's only
gonna be this oh we only good three
years
just the live service and then that's
when things start slowly move towards
you know what's fun inevitably a base
quote unquote hated from the beginning
with you because they know part of that
base is going to be resisted and I think
that they're setting that up just to be
honest but again there are some that is
pointing this out but I've noticed that
uh some people aren't saying this on
Twitter which is when he was referring
to free to play games the lives as a
service game he's referring about Last
of Us factions oh yeah like that is
that's coming to PC day and day yeah
that is a strong point how about this
factions will also be on PS4 that is
PS4 he's not really Herman house is not
willing to get like listen this is money
and first of all live service and I had
to correct shout out to the whole ACG I
always tell people I am not no longer of
the mindset of live service games being
exclusive it makes no sense you have to
have the majority of the base wherever
they are so you want more engagement it
makes sense for them to put it on PC day
one it makes sense for them even like
Alex said PS4 that's a huge base sitting
there
a lot of people are going to be
emotional again get ready and only what
is happening one percent buy games
before before you go let me read these
two super chats I don't want these yeah
I'm like all right no problem bro yeah
please
um if God of War is buggy I'm selling my
PlayStation you're lying
[Laughter]
stop it real got a 35 month uh message
from practical Eagle loving this guest
so much common sense with the hilarious
delivery never heard of them before
hold on someone someone in the chat
hustle if you're there uh uh I spam uh
Alex's uh Channel some of the best stuff
You're gonna laugh absolutely fantastic
content I don't care
if you want to learn about PC ports as
well things like that you're very
knowledgeable in that respect to
continue
oh that's all oh now we gotta shoot all
the super shot from Tom from Toonami I
love that name I've never heard that
that must have come from you Alex uh
Spider-Man 2 and Wolverine cross gin pin
it I don't oh yeah I I don't I don't
think I'm gonna jump on that one I think
they're going to be PS5 exclusive 99
okay
yeah I'll do that oh here we go
on Spider-Man and Wolverine uh not being
crossed so you said so addict you're
saying so YouTube only
no yeah I'm saying PS5 Only You bucking
up on me
yup I'm not doing a bend the needle Buck
I'm doing a bend the knee with King so
the question hold on let's set the rules
of engagement right if that game is on
the PlayStation 4 he in trouble so
basically there will be no ps4 version
yes of Wolverine and that was it just
that game that's out of his mind
Wolverine and Spider-Man will be
PlayStation 5 games
didn't they do it where there was like
six months later they put a game back on
like God yeah was like perversely put
back so like a statue of limitations so
I will get my knees back and here I have
to throw them right back at me after
when they do it it's okay you know
what's funny speaking of that you know
we get 500 likes me and King will will
talk about the God
Awards I already tweeted that stuff out
I tweet it out when you were asleep he
tried to get his knees he tried to get
his knees until it's in the store is
this official or not so we don't know
okay so so King you're saying PS4 is on
the PlayStation he's done son all right
cool it's official it's official how it
goes is Wolverine and Spiderman
they all gonna be there
you're done continue so Wolverine and
Spider-Man cannot be on the PlayStation
4 or he uh or I lose right if it's only
on PlayStation 5 it can be on PC2 but as
far as consoles if it can only be on
Playstation 5. I'm worried about the
place what happens if there's one of
them makes it and the other one don't
just to clarify just to clarify you will
not bend the knee on the God of War
until the release date
you ain't going down with the ship
mine
the Titanic music is playing we know
what's happening
I'll be playing the game and still don't
give you
put the logos in the chat for McFly
Walker okay yeah I join yeah and then we
got another two dollars to track from
Tom from Toonami also I'll bend the knee
well I guess I'm taking two knees all
right yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
get like one of those little saws that
was in saw you know so that that that's
all good cool King did you get your
balls and we could move on to this last
topic oh man this is so fantastic
all you frauds would you please stand up
please frauds
calling out to the front of the
congregation
it'll never be damned damn PC never
right
you like PlayStation is too illustrious
that's what y'all do y'all do bogging
basement stuff that's inside Game Pass
then dick we don't gotta do that we
gotta put nothing then deep who the hell
dude y'all wait for our greatness y'all
yo
started effectively
all games of a service
day and date
PC
Nexus you up
Nexus is on Deck looking like Barry
Bonds oh man
74.
um oh man shout out the father twitch
laughing now now now now
the best part about it what's the best
part the best part about it
remember that four years old man them
games is four years old they got over
there yeah
it wasn't see dudes get it yep that's
true one year out yo it's literally she
keeps cheating on you bro
literally she keeps cheating you keep
finding different socks in the drawer oh
man not like this oh how many Footprints
you're gonna have around your bed before
you wake up and see you know what
something's going on
something's going on
the situation the PCS PC is rocking the
house
and you can't keep up with this
bandwidth
you're in trouble son he has higher
resolution than you yo all the stuff
look better over here it's an
all-natural situation on PC yo at what
point in time do you you can't even say
all Natty on your own stuff
because it looks better over there and
it comes out day and day you're not
special anymore your special card is
taken away and look at you now I love
this you're hurt good looking bro I
waited all week I had my mouth shut I
said these dudes I got a net I caught
all of you yo you got PlayStation fans
laughing at themselves right now this is
great you know the best part about this
Cold Hard Cash says
that one year out stuff is gonna go away
real quick cause that Zeitgeist oh yeah
facts they want to be in the mix because
listen to be honest with you I don't
really care if a game I don't I don't
care where the games has launched that
as long as where I want to pick it up at
facts I could pick it up right I don't
care it doesn't affect me if somebody
else has fun cars
it doesn't affect me bars so who am I to
say I don't want that released over
there why
what is your what is your big gripe
because you don't feel special anymore
with your shiny little plastic box
listen let me tell you something I can
tell you why you should never feel
special again I'm gonna tell you why
I'm baseball
launch day and Dayton Game Pass oh you
thought that MLB the Show talk oh my God
that's the first party uh title there
day in date mm-hmm
on another console you wasn't special
Denny looked you in your face and said
you wasn't special in the city hold on
hold hold my beer 70 for you
oh man oh man
not the 70v she letting the other dude
hit for free
not like this
ah
not like this all I say is
when are you gonna wake up
at what point of time are you gonna wake
up and say they don't really care about
me like I think they do
she don't really like you like that oh
man
yo they lied to you about the SSD I'm
the dude to go and tell you
they lied about that when Ratchet and
Clank comes all over you're gonna see
him oh man a lot again
listen
they they lied about a lot of things to
you guys and y'all just keep making
iterations yeah remember that
Generations now we talk about four years
then we're gonna stop
you know what he did he did like filled
it when Jim said yo you know the
contract is up in 20 to 24. it'll start
to give you three more years Jim gave
y'all three more years
yeah
I gotta catch your bike you do it too
much you do it too much
gun the bushes and find you frauds
y'all can't run for me
you can't lead these people alone stop
put sugar in your gas tank your car
don't worry
[Laughter]
he has some more statements the
initiative is still going to go on you
know as far as supporting the PC also
mobile they stressing mobile cross play
as well as an important initiative get
ready for that and um yeah like you said
the like Alex said eloquently expect
more of the cross-generational as far as
the live service games and then you know
day and dating that and we'll see what
happens with single player but yep it is
what it is I'm just gonna put my on this
last topic attic if you don't mind so we
could just just go and then we can do
some checks in the end OverWatch
OverWatch 2 addict it has launched a lot
of things going on with this title
um what are your thoughts sir this is
your topic
oh hold on hold on I got a break
protocol free R Kelly has has balls for
you too he's here he's back he's fresh
out of confidence you know here we go
Kane it's over turn your Xbox into a hot
plate
does it yeah
[Laughter]
Fair King he only spent two dollars
oh okay he ran out of minutes all right
okay let's go to bed all right cool
we'll go to your attic with your tablet
OverWatch 2's out it had a pretty shaky
launch uh you know the game functions
decently at at the moment but you know
I played uh for those of you that know I
did streamer for about two hours
it's OverWatch one uh I I guess me in
particular I didn't really care if it
was like a huge jump forward I just
missed playing OverWatch and I missed
OverWatch having more updates and stuff
uh so it's like I personally felt like
they didn't need to do like this giant
jump over with like making an OverWatch
too uh they could have done something
maybe similar to like Destiny 2 did
where they said well look we're not
making a destiny 3 we're just gonna add
on to Destiny 2. but it's just it's a
lot of weird stuff that they're doing
like it's it's kind of taking that that
market and going to a free to play so
they tried this like cell phone thing
and they didn't realize it was it was
stopping people that didn't have like an
actual provider like ATT Verizon Sprint
which was which was interesting by
itself then they're locking some of the
heroes behind a battle pass which is
weird or by itself which I
it's like
well if you actually played the other
one they're not all locked I had yeah so
if you played the first one then you do
have access to them but if you haven't
played the first one or bought the hero
pack for forty dollars you have to play
a hundred games to unlock the original
hero cast and then if you didn't buy the
battle pass or had the original game or
buy the hero pack then you have to then
start grinding out the battle pass to
get the other Heroes like kiriko and
stuff like that can you doing as their
crew God I was gonna say I don't know
because I already had them can you buy
the heroes individual like Apex Legends
I'm not entirely sure okay chat tell me
have you been able to actually play the
game it hasn't worked it had saved for
me I can't even come it's been working
decently uh yesterday and today but like
I said me and my girl try to play that
for three days and she was just like I'm
uninstalling it I'm done I'm not trying
this anymore okay I'm not fair enough a
lot of it's not a good game play TF2
instead
was going to say onyx so what are your
thoughts on launch a lot of stuff going
on obviously the D Dawson I think yeah
this is no the the dancing is [ __ ]
and then it's a fact that uh that's a
it's a Smoking Gun or like [ __ ] I
think this is the same thing we have
with Diablo 3
that was
um with error 43 you guys remember that
I keep forgetting it's Sunday you guys I
appreciate you appreciate you man thank
you you've done good though you're good
for about three topics strong it was
good yeah yeah and then you know it
kicks in
um he's just when he keeps leaving he go
he he's he's taking a couple shots
I should get sponsored by Tito's uh no
so the thing is like talking you've got
is an online game that is not really
free to play because you either spend
your time or you spend your money right
and that's the problem so
I mean the only thing OverWatch is
actually good for is for the rule 34
that you see on the Hub for OverWatch
that's the only reason why the game's
even successful
I mean I'm being as blatant as I can
like the map design is bad it's all
based on choke points the fact that they
are locking characters that are team
based and class ability based with comps
behind a paywall it's also a bad thing
to do you know like loot boxes were
actually a better call that's what
you're wearing yeah people living in the
Forum saying that they actually missed
the loot boxes
yeah because like it's like okay well
they were just kids at least I had the
heroes I think but now you're like
you're now you're sacrificing comps so
if we're playing a game and I don't have
the battle passenger played the first
one and you guys are setting up a
specific comp for a meta I'm bringing
the team down because I can't do the
confidence necessary yeah so then what
happens is now I have four people
screaming at me to either go buy the 100
battle pass or just to not play and get
kicked and then I can't do the game so
that's the problem
I think the biggest issue I have with
the game is
not only did they switch it to a free to
play Not only did they log Heroes that
people
would be coming into it's like imagine
playing something and then people was
like yo that support's not doing nothing
switched to Marcy we need more direct
healing oh God Mercy
it's just like and not only all that but
then when you look at the actual content
you have
they didn't give us no content like it's
literally OverWatch one so like no
matter
I haven't seen one and I've played a
good uh like probably 10 15 games I
haven't seen one new math there might be
a new map but it's just like Fall Guys
when you when the new season shows up
there's a playlist for like two weeks
that lets you play nothing but the new
stuff they don't have nothing like that
it's just like look you want to jump on
here
you can you could do it but it's just
like we're not gonna really offer any
type of
uh you know stuff to get anything done
and just like look OverWatch is still
fun but I guess me it's like I would
have been more accepting with the other
stuff a little bit if they actually gave
me new content to play but they didn't
so it's just like I play a couple games
and I'm like okay let's go back to
ground like okay no it's interesting
anyone else thoughts who got who who got
a chance to get in King did you get a
chance to get it that game was never on
my radar um
I was probably on my radar to play with
Bill shout out to the great uh before
um I thought about it I said uh when I
get a chance to but then I heard all the
trouble that was going on with the
d-dawson and stuff and the the people
that came uh they claimed uh to be doing
it gave their reasons behind it and it
was like a political in nature uh okay
so then you take out this political
agenda
on the consumers the your people you
your guys right makes absolutely no
sense
um because you think you're hitting
these guys bottom line stupid
oh my hair all the grind and stuff I
don't know how to work that if it's free
right and they got to make money so yeah
loot crates and loot boxes everybody was
saying that was a Cancer and they had
all these regulations and stuff put in
because they said it was predatory yeah
they didn't do it was because of the
regulations being made that's why they
they went away from the loot box right
so this is what you get
right Luke loot boxes and loot crates or
whatever was there y'all made a fuss
about it and this is the result
now go grind
go grind or buck up and pay up that's it
that's it don't cry
yeah but are you saying the loot boxes
would be all right then no listen listen
I'm I'm a fraud
okay I'm a fraud I don't care about the
game I'm a fraud if I cared about the
game then I can give you an honest
assessment of what's going on listen
my thing is
if you're in a in a match with your
friends and they said don't use that guy
go use the other girl or whatever and
you don't have a we kick you out cause
you broke so why are you here go buy her
from the store and get back in the room
and go heal the people while we fight
I'm done that's it it's very simple so
it happened in Diablo Immortal too yeah
this is about economics right and it
both in that scenario happened to
somebody it was like yo did you do you
have such and such because we're
building a team he was like oh no I
don't have the DLC how many times has
that happened to people in Destiny you
don't have the DLC how many times have
they say oh my God where Mercedes where
my Stadium go I mean my um my stasis go
throw the subclass yeah I lost I lost
stasis when they took it out of Game
Pass now go buy it
now get up and go buy it or you can't
use it right so it's they think they're
entitled to things they gave you a way
to get it now if you don't want to spend
money go grind one of the two either
spend your time or spend your cash or we
gave you the game
talking about oh it's Bare Bones it's
free shut up
oh God no I don't accept that
because because a piece of dog crap can
be free still dogcraft I won't take it
I won't take it but if I like that it's
coming with me
you know that's the whole thing like
just because something's free doesn't
mean you should you should use it or
like accept the fact that it can't be
better and okay so and to that point
that you're saying
then teach them don't play their game
let me ask you this to King's Point in
defense what about because as I I agree
with you right but what about that the
numbers and analytics of these companies
have right that Gamers always bend the
knee in the long run yeah complaining we
we are a nickel chamber we're a very
small niche of people exactly a lot of
people like as loud as we can get it's
not going to matter like so I have a
saying like everyone is a is a three
minute trailer away from a pre-order
preach and talk that talk thank you this
is the three minute trailer right away
if you're just forgetting all the bad
stuff preach it you know like oh you're
a horrible company trailer comes out oh
day one bro day one bro we in
I agree so you know people just want to
play that game or they'll they'll do
what they want to play it if so my thing
is like if you don't want to deal with
that so like I like I have a really big
problem with valve and how they're
treating Counter-Strike just 100 the
fact that they still don't have 128 tick
servers they still have cheating issues
back is broken like all kinds of stuff
too
but like they're like oh check out these
new skin boxes
it's like why Bro you've got one of the
best games of all time and this is what
you're gonna do like how you're fixing
it so I don't know it's
I think the thing is with blizzard what
they should have done was make the game
completely free have all the characters
that just release them naturally you buy
them that way and you just have a free
battle pass and then the the bot battle
pass the bot battle pass has legendary
skins and the free battle pass does it
and that's it I'll figure how do we
gotta run we have time look
um I'll make very quick same thing look
this is
Corporation is going to cooperate and to
me they've made a conscious decision
this is no longer uh what is it 40 to 60
game and yeah free to play they looked
at what the model is they looked at the
the or what you call the the fortnights
the Apex Legends they want that
engagement and as much as we're saying
what we want and I know this service is
bad at launch I'm look this ain't my
first rodeo with live service in Destiny
Games I know the first two days are
always the worst now this dude does seem
exceptionally bad but I will say that to
me they will rather deal with this and
they look at okay we had 10 million when
we did a launch with OverWatch one but
now we got 100 or whatever that number
that metric is that's what they care
about because they're free to play not a
sad part is like Alex and Al Attica
saying which is the nickel and Diamond
of characters to a meta like that's
terrible like you can't play with a
character you can't you have to buy it
and then I heard the track like the free
track is really grindy like it's
from the old one just basic stuff it's
really a monetization model and they're
going extra already the key is going to
be like like I said all Gamers truly
going to put their foot down and force
them to say okay you know what the
engagement is low people are pushing
back let's capitulate and and make these
changes and that's gonna be the key and
we're gonna see I I've always been the
standpoint like the game's out the thing
is the people that's willing to actually
stand up bucker down they're not in huge
masses that's good it's just there's
been very few times in gaming where
people came together and got something
stopped
um I've always felt like people like
vote for your wall vote in your wallet
doesn't do anything because the majority
of people don't know what's going on
they just buy it
so I've always like as long as you ain't
calling people some crazy stuff go on
Twitter tag OverWatch tag blizzard tag
activation because what that's what I
said as long you're not saying crazy
stuff so like they're more inclined to
change stuff when the community managers
of these people wake up get on Twitter
to 15 000 people saying I'm not happy
and then do it you do it every day
because that's going to get stuff more
changed than voting with your wallet I'm
not saying go out there and support the
stuff but it's just like I've always
said it's like I said they got you by
the Hobby and it's just like you know it
sucks I love OverWatch it it puts me in
a situation where it's like do I want to
not play a game that I've always enjoyed
playing or do I want to not play a game
because of the bad practices that
they're doing and it's it is especially
hard for me to do it because where I
played so much OverWatch one I got all
the characters
it's like it doesn't affect me but like
when my girl joins she she gonna have
like two characters online so it's just
like look like
go on Twitter tag everyone you can think
of Mike your bar all of them be like yo
I don't like what you're doing with
blizzard I don't like what you're doing
with uh with with OverWatch I feel like
you guys are making a mistake you sure
you might not get into it but you know
what what's more effective
50 000 people not buying a game which
that that's some numbers but when you
considering these games sell millions
it's not really a lot or 50 000 people
tweeting these people every day saying
what's going on
that's going to be the game is they're
going to speak at the end of the day but
look that's all I got let's wrap this
thing up let's get the pole and go with
the recent statements by hand of
PlayStation Studios Herman Holst that
Sony live service games will launch day
and date with PC and console do you
think that single player games will
eventually do the same the choices are a
no Sony values the importance single
play experiences and does not require
them day and day for their business
model B yes Sony recognize the value of
more revenue and new audience introduced
to single player games at the height of
the Zeitgeist or C I don't care all this
mobile cross Play Talk where's my Vita 2
at though that was the choices please
Rock the vote when it goes up on Twitter
shout out to the legendary thigh in the
game the most electric Channel right now
in YouTube oh no it's Alex tell the five
people from where they can find you what
you got going on Sir yeah uh youtube.com
oh no it's Alex you can also follow me
on Twitter same thing
um I don't stream on Twitch but it's
there uh videos go up uh Tuesday to
Friday I don't do videos on Mondays I'm
tired and uh live streams are on
Saturdays so if you think you like the
content and then you want to go that
extra level deeper then you come on show
up on Saturday like that's where that's
where the wild stuff happens so check it
out thank you guys so much no doubt much
love put the channel in chat go
subscribe to the channel fantastic
I'm sorry the reason he doesn't do
content on Mondays is because he's too
hungover first
absolute pleasure long overdue good to
see you doing your thing man I had a lot
of fun and thank you for rocking out I
know we go super low so yeah I
appreciate it and all that good stuff
to be honest with you he goes about the
same distance on Saturdays he'd be doing
that stuff forever
that's crazy that's crazy real quick oh
I didn't say some Boston to Alex before
you head out yeah I appreciate you
coming on man uh you know I I've known
this man for like six years at this
point man it's been a long time I I need
to get out you just invited him now
and what's funny is if unless you
deleted them
we can find me inviting you to the IOP
oh we got the results
but I told you I told you as I remodeled
my house
oh man yo so much fun
um I showed my wifey a video yesterday
of uh the steam deck I think that was
the first one that popped up because I
was like yo we haven't um oh no it's
Alex on and um she was like who's that I
was like no I was like you don't
remember the guy that I watched and you
know
shoulder the video she's like oh yeah
you gotta have him on I was like yeah
yeah she's like well because she texts
me now she said are you okay
you okay I said me and I'm having a
great time
um and and probably was a little bit
extra today yeah I have to turn it up a
notch yeah both was turning up right for
when you come in because your show was
fantastic and it gives me great laughs
so if I can give you some lives today
that was me giving you a gift to you no
doubt uh the same way that you give me
that gift of laughter so I love what you
do fantastic stuff don't stop you don't
doing what you're doing and I had a
great time today no doubt appreciate
love it was having fun no doubt actually
we got to go it's all good we're just
gonna do these super chants and rock out
yeah thank you guys so much for having
me oh no doubt I gotta go all right
brother have a great weekend have a good
one bro have a good one bye attic I need
your help on the super chats I don't to
be honest with that I don't know where
he ended oh man like no when I read the
super chats that I saw but I have no
clue if I missed any after between them
okay
okay
tell me tell us what the last one was no
no they they they got thumbs up okay let
me see what happens what's the last chat
you guys remember solver totally
unprofessional because I don't remember
so I don't remember let me go back to
install
all right because I'm looking at the
super chats now and I've read a few of
these but I don't remember what the last
one he read all right
all right see anything sounds familiar
[Music]
damn that's so much
yeah I'm still young but I got a bad
memory don't be sitting there coming at
me like that Lord Metro I got a bad
memory move a lot yo and it seemed like
the what you call a joint ain't catch up
oh
let me Let me refresh this
is all right so what I'm gonna do is
all right is she like why I got October
8th date instead October
all right what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
just read
back like 10 super chats uh if you
didn't tell me if you guys heard him say
it or not uh somebody who who's sleeping
who somebody woke a sleeping something
it won't show me his own name breaking
news PSR re-bleach okay I remember him
seeing that one okay uh hard get shitty
with the 10 shirt you can expect similar
cash out to the most of the okay I
remember that one five dollar super trap
from clutchman 01 just woke up to the oh
notes okay I remember that one Sebastian
H with the two dollar Super Chat shout
out to uh Sony without staff uh said
stuff doing remakes I think we're gonna
talk about that one too post up with the
ten dollar Super Chat
the ab acquisition was never about Cod
it's always been about putting my the he
read that one
um NC ghost of low road with the 20
super trap my question would be if
PlayStation brand is determine uh okay I
think my plate my question would be is
PlayStation a brand like Nintendo to
determine if you see anything past the
ps6 because the moves they make seem to
be in I can't we did that one okay he
did that one Lord breakfast to the five
Super Chat I don't care how much dance
moves out in these streets snitching
okay uh Sebastian H Alex okay I think
this is a two dollar subscribe for Alex
Alex in the bald men podcast
okay ten dollars from NC ghost uh
Spider-Man being the exception is Kratos
for last of us being a brand that can
match the same popularity or enough
people buying games there or Cod flame
with the two dollar Super Chat yep we
did that one which is saw I mean he said
um stop cheesing me Jim I remember that
Lord Metro with the two dollars we could
try to solve you use
Alberto
yeah after shaving I think we're right
here I think this is it because now NC
ghost of low low low Red Road you got
two ounces and they killed my Dreamcast
with their DVD player two sure we did
one-way dragonfly let's not forget the
gambling bodies are there to protect the
consumers okay cool Target 20 Super Chat
to King's Point when PlayStation came
into the market we had turbo gravity
yeah okay uh NC goes to low roll two
dollar what goes around comes around
book of Acts no 2001 okay here we go GSD
getting he just said we did that like
eight times a week and he can go no no
he don't he remembers he remembers
get his stuff done 10 out Super Chat
check hogue's latest video about this
thing about saying Brazil is its own
country that caught was it wasn't a top
seller there EU Britain and USC are
different but shouldn't stop it told you
the streams would be cool
he did say that shot the hole yeah baby
father ten dollar Super Chat Microsoft
saw what happened to that flicks where
Disney and Paramount started pulling
their content to start their own
Services they even hired Netflix execs
own the majority of the IP is the plan
yes Rel two dollar Super Chat all
PlayStation 5 have I I've read all okay
you did Tom from Toonami Spider-Man 2
okay
Wolverine will be on Xbox Sony does it
own the IP wow spicy
um free R Kelly
2013 you play it's a hot plate that's
what I broke protocol 108 Dragon TV two
dot Super Chat free to play suck hence
these actions charge me please
all right also shout out to Fozzy uh
with the final Super Chat you guys have
been on fire the last few weeks pretty
much last month to the eye and salute to
the Iowa it's a little homie Post stop
you already know follow some chat will
Microsoft do the same with OverWatch 2
that they did with Riot games with Game
Pass interesting yeah so good that is
actually a good possibility they'll
probably do uh did we get any
merchandise
um um I got I'll check in a second just
check it wasn't any other super chats
after post no there wasn't all right
cool let me checked merch solve we miss
you already come back
um let's see
I know we have some uh what you call us
let's see nope shout out to Harvey he's
sending me uh screenshots of the ones
that we uh missed but okay cool no doubt
about the target attic where can I find
people find you what you got going on
Sir now that we caught up you can find
me on Twitter at Lord addict IOP you can
also find me on YouTube at gaming addict
I'm a revamp that channel you should go
and see the content I'm doing on there
now but I'm going to do different stuff
I'm going to run that channel a little
differently you can also find me
about to go eat because I'm hungry
uh you know it was a good show we had up
to I think almost 900. here you guys
show up here every day you know we got
those likes up man hit that like button
600 people we ain't at 600 likes I don't
like that I think you guys can do better
than that man you when you hit that like
button just to visualize you giving me
energy it's king with that Spirit Bomb
he out of pocket again
a little kid making a five people five
sir
um because I'm I was texting my wife at
the same time right yeah she was like is
everything okay are you yelling at
somebody
and I had to text and say
when two comedians is in the room
they're gonna
mentally combat with each other on who
can be the funniest I respect his comedy
yeah he's funny as hell I respect it
because his comedy is so funny if I if
you can make me laugh out loud
then I find you truly funny so I had to
bring the comedy today
so it was on fire for sure we had a
great day yes and hopefully I gave him
enough material
oh you were purposely giving material
you were going extra extra you were like
it's like click me bro
it was it was so much fun I'm not gonna
lie
um very rarely do we get guests that can
take a joke and give a joke and have a
good time and you know I didn't feel
like I had to tiptoe around certain
things or anything
um so it was a fantastic day um
Sovereign I hope everything works out
everything's fantastic addict talk to
you later uh Cog fantastic stuff hosting
and doing the things that you love
and I I do want to point out real quick
you know we we are so close to a
thousand followers on Tick Tock uh you
know we we can have a bit of tic tac
look at it yeah so yeah I'm gonna put
that in here even if you guys don't be
rocking to talk that much you know you
might just pop in for a couple minutes
and then pop out you know definitely go
in there you'll uh follow us on Tick
Tock man help us get to that thousand
man we close we like we like 50 60 away
we mad close but definitely gone there
uh the the grounded video you saw before
I'll probably see uh get Cog to play it
again uh after the show okay uh we we're
gonna be trying to do more of that here
coming out forward the good thing about
those is all of us don't have to be
present for that you know we could
always rotate people out and I think
rotating people ought to actually make
better content in general because you
have a different perspective and not
just like you know let's say me soft
King and Carl could do that every week
you would eventually get tired of us
doing that every week so it's nice that
we can you know ingermingle and have
different perspectives than these so
we'll try to do that a little bit more
it's probably gonna be grounded for a
little bit because we I I'm obsessed
with killing spiders
I'm afraid of them
get back no down salute against his
blump sauce and some love oh no it's
Alex was in the building salute to the
chat everybody up in there man yeah got
some more stuff the other week next week
and uh more fun stuff planned for the
year but that's all I got want to do
this program but anything else you got
for me attic yeah oh Volaris pillows oh
yeah information coming in soon yes if
you want that valari you know what I'm
saying pull up I see a lot of you
talking I got to see some of you pull up
yes pull up we're gonna have some real
news to break soon it will be super lit
that's all I got anything else we out of
here
whatever
there you go everybody up here there we
go let's go over here it's real though
still
I feel like we're making a mistake I
don't know why but I feel like
we're about to come across like a giant
spider or something
uh hold on Adam you go without the light
man
what's up here what's up here are we
back to the other side
[Music]
where's Costco
I'm going out the other way
you didn't come with us wait I saw that
spider I'm going out the other way
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you